Hey,
what's up everybody?
This episode of the Joe Rogan is parents is brought to you by lumosity.com this
is the time of the year.
We're all looking for ways to build good habits.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's new years.
It's a,
it's not really new year's.
It's bullshit time doesn't give a fuck about you.
How about that?
How about a time?
Doesn't care about the universe,
doesn't care about solar systems.
Living and dying time is infinite and it only exists,
but for us,
you need a clock and a calendar,
so get your shit together.
You're lazy bitch.
Stop using the fact that time isn't real as an excuse and go to lumosity.com
Lumosity is essentially,
it's like a website gym for your brain.
They have brain games that are designed by top scientists to train mental
processes.
I say that because there's a Canadian guest on my podcast.
They like to say processes,
processes.
The Americans will say processes,
uh,
best parts.
They're fun,
challenging,
and they only take a few minutes every day.
One time you can track your progress online and can be over time.
Rather,
you can track your progress on time and compare yourself to other people,
which is a dick thing to do.
You know,
really just worry about yourself.
Stop.
I mean,
maybe be inspired by other people,
but don't be like,
Hey Bob,
what was your score?
Lumosity Myrna was better.
Uh,
I play it.
you can play it on an iPad.
It's pretty cool just sitting around.
You can design these games,
uh,
based on the things that you're looking to acquire,
whether you're looking to acquire a better memory or you're looking to acquire.
You know,
there's,
if you go to the website itself,
there's a bunch of different options like memory you can put recalling the
location of objects,
remembering names after the first introduction,
learning new subjects quickly and accurately.
And the beautiful thing about it is it feels like a game.
It's just something fun that you can do that is actually good for your brain.
Uh,
go to lumosity.com/joe,
that's lumosity.com/joe and go check it out.
You freaks.
It's an awesome way to do something productive.
It's actually fun in your spare time.
And it's healthy for your brain.
I'm for,
I firmly believe in it.
I use them.
I think that playing chess,
playing games,
doing things that makes your brain think steps ahead,
it uses your brain the same way.
We use our muscles the same way we use our cardiovascular system.
We we exercise and we get stronger because of it.
I think the same works with your mind.
So read a book bitch.
All right.
We're also brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is one of my favorite podcast sponsors because we know so many
people that have,
am I too loud here?
Yeah,
it's all of them.
Is it right here?
Is that better?
That's great.
Think Squarespace is an all in one platform to design your own website.
That's super easy.
Click,
drag,
drop.
It's an super simple interface.
They offer 24 seven support.
Every design automatically includes a unique mobile experience that matches the
overall style of your website,
so your content will look great on every device,
every time.
That's like iPads,
android tablets,
laptops,
windows,
the whole deal.
It's,
he was super easy and you know,
this is something that a long time ago it was virtually impossible a long time
ago.
One of the big things about websites is like you would get a website that would
work really well and internet explorer,
but then we tried to use it on Firefox.
It was shit.
It was a real issue for web coders,
not any more.
This is the easiest time in the history of the universe for making a website for
a free trial and 10% off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com and enter the offer code Joe and the number one that's Joe
and the number one because we are in the month of January.
Squarespace is also putting on a contest now for j r e listeners and it's a
website design contest.
And here's what you need to do.
Go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe sign up and get 10% off your first
purchase.
Then build a website.
It's super easy to do and once you've built your bad ass website,
tweet it to Hashtag j r e Squarespace.
That's one word,
Hashtag j r e Squarespace before January 17th and I'm going to pick four winners
who have designed the most beautiful websites and Squarespace.
We'll send these winters a swag bag with items like a Squarespace apple keyboard
tee shirt,
a mole skin and more.
So visit squarespace.com right now and use the offer code Joe and the number one
to build your website and then tweet your website Hashtag j r e Squarespace.
We are also brought to you by on it o n n I.
T.
What is on it?
If you've heard this website,
have you heard this podcast and you heard me talk about this website,
you probably totally tired of hearing about it at this point in time.
Uh,
it's a human optimization website and what we tried to do it on it is offer you
the best things that we can find as far as strength and conditioning equipment
like kettle bells as far as protein supplements like hemp force and different
foods that we sell that are like we have like buffalo bars and organic coconut
oil.
Just things that I believe are good for your health.
And supplements that I believe benefit cognitive function benefits your ability
to perform a athletic tasks and it gives you a bit more endurance.
There's a lot of science out there that's been done into the,
the,
the science of athletics supplementation.
And you know,
there's not a lot that really work.
It's,
it's hard to find something that really works significantly.
One of them that works significantly is called cordyceps mushrooms.
The fascinating one that was the first figured out by the Chinese Olympic team.
It's based on a mushroom that they noticed these,
these cattle eating these mushrooms in high altitudes and they became more
active when they saw the meanness.
And so they were trying to figure out like,
why are they more active when they,
when they're eating this mushroom,
will they figured out that it actually enhances your body's ability to process
oxygen?
It's all fascinating shit.
Um,
all the supplements that on ana.com all of them have a 90 day 30 pill,
100% money back guarantee.
So if you're confused or if you're like,
man,
I don't know if this stuff really works.
Like new mood was a five HTP supplement,
which actually is a natural way of boosting serotonin.
And what's interesting about it is that doctors who were putting people on
antidepressants oftentimes tell them to not take five HTP because then you'll
have too much that good shit in your brain,
which seems to me maybe it's just strict to fire rich trip for,
you know what I'm saying?
But what am I,
what am I a doctor?
No,
I'm not even close.
All right,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t use the code name Rogan and save 10%.
A lot of new stuff if you haven't been there before or if you haven't been there
in wild digestive enzymes and um,
the new primal kettle bells,
which are all chimpanzees and Zombie kettlebells.
Lots of fun stuff.
O n n I t use the Codeword Rogan.
All right.
Stefan Molyneux is here.
Let's not waste any more time and cue the music.
Young Jamie
jail.
Well,
good experience Joe Rogan podcast.
I've been looking forward to doing this podcast with you again for awhile and
uh,
I knew exactly what was going to happen.
Unfortunately,
when you got here,
as soon as you sit down,
we start talking about so much cool stuff before the podcast even starts.
We needed a prequel.
Yeah,
man,
we're already into temperatures and uh,
there's a lot of different things,
but no,
no need to go back over all that stuff again.
I'm very excited to talk to you because there's been a lot of things that,
um,
first of all,
I've really enjoyed our first podcast,
really fun conversation in Toronto,
but there's a lot of things that I,
uh,
I read online and I say,
hmm,
I wonder how Stephanie would deal with this.
I wonder what your take on this is because you've got some very strong opinions
on where taxes should go and you know,
what money should be spent on that benefits the community.
And I agree with a lot of them.
I think they're very fascinating.
The France thing,
have you seen this France thing where they're jacking up the tax,
the 75%
yeah.
I mean talk about killing the goose that lays the golden egg.
You know,
we,
and it's,
it's sad because everybody's seriously thinks that it's going to be somebody
else who's taxed.
Exactly.
They keep creeping it down.
It's like,
let's go get those rich people and tax them.
And then it's like you get a mirror and it's like,
what me?
No,
no,
no.
The rich people.
But now it's getting to the point like they could tax all of the rich people in
America and it would pay the government for like three days.
I mean,
it's all complete nonsense.
It's just the way of setting us against each other.
So we missed the whole reality of what's going on.
It's a piss poor management solution to,
it's a terrible idea to take the people that are earning the most and take a
massively disproportionate amount of out of
money from them.
And so,
you know,
they're talking about like pro athletes and clubs,
soccer clubs and corporations and you know,
the very highest of the high,
but still 75% is fucking ridiculous.
No one deserves to give
you 75% of what they've earned yet,
maybe a little bit more.
You know,
I agree that as a person who's made a good amount of money in my life,
I agree that I should pay a lot of taxes.
I don't mind paying a lot of taxes.
I don't mind,
but I'm not going to give you more than half.
That's fucking ridiculous.
You can't get more than half.
You're not doing it right.
You're not spending the money right.
We can,
you,
you can get more than half when you give me a fucking complete analysis of every
penny where it went,
what it benefited,
I want,
Oh,
we actually living in paradise.
You know,
like if we're floating on clouds and we get like we shit rainbows and all that,
then you can get all my tax money.
And when there's no poverty and the children are all living peacefully and the
schools are gorgeous and glowing temples of knowledge,
then maybe,
but at the moment,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
sorry.
Do you need more money for this war in Iraq?
I have a slight problem with that.
Yeah,
I'm all out of money for you,
dude.
Same Way.
The guy with the sign,
the homeless sign in the corner that like smile and he flips it over it like
it's bent.
You know,
could you spare a dollar?
And then he flips it over like you've got this crafty sign.
Use that,
that mind that made that crafty sign.
Go get a fucking job.
You crazy.
Fuck you know,
Jesus Christ.
If it's possible for you,
you can get a job.
And if it's not possible for you to get a job,
we as a society should take those people off the street and put them in mental
institutions.
Give them help.
Well,
okay.
Okay.
So if,
go ahead,
drum,
drag corn at the topic if you dare,
but I dare,
there is this interesting thing around
poverty,
right?
Poverty.
A lot of times people really feel like,
oh,
you know,
they just had some bad luck.
It's a real shame,
you know,
they're just,
things didn't go quite the right way.
But you know,
statistically that the majority of people,
like if you take the average of how much people work in a household below the
poverty line,
you got two people in a household below the poverty line.
On average,
they work 16 hours a week between the two of them.
Whoa.
Now that is it to some degree,
poverty by choice.
And I don't mind,
hey,
wouldn't it be great to only work 60 hours a week?
Especially if your options are jobs that are kind of crappy,
which we all generally start with those jobs that are crappy.
But to me that's a,
and that doesn't change whether the economy is good or bad.
So it's not like where they'd like to work more with the can't find the work.
And that's just one of those uncomfortable truths.
A lot of poverty is voluntary and it's nice to be poor because it's a whole lot
less work and people get all the benefits out of not working or which are
considerable,
you know?
I mean,
I guess daytime TV is good for a lot of people and uh,
uh,
so,
but,
but then what happens is then they need money for something.
They get sick and suddenly poverty becomes this huge problem.
But a lot of poverty,
it's like monks,
you know,
amongst the poor,
but you know,
they don't need charity cause they're kind of choosing that lifestyle and it's
not true of all of the poor.
But on average,
a lot of people who are poor,
they don't particularly like to work.
And you know,
again,
I don't mind that,
but except the consequences of that,
don't you think that it's really difficult to break out of a cycle?
That's the real issue that I've always had with people shitting on people who
are poor or people who live in poor neighborhoods for not getting out.
It's very difficult to break a cycle.
And if you're born into a of
poverty and of neglect and of laziness and a lack of ambition,
it's very hard to break out of that cycle.
And then also you're dealing with a really down economy where it's difficult to
get a job that pays good money,
they're all taken,
there's more people looking for jobs and there are jobs.
And a,
it's a real issue for a lot of people that,
you know,
don't really have an education or don't have a particular sentence
or even if you do,
I got,
I did a colon show while I was here in California and the guy called in and he
said,
you know,
I just graduated as a pharmacist,
like illegal pusher.
And for me it's like,
okay,
pharmacist in America,
if there's one thing that's recession proof,
because you know,
when people are down,
they get,
they take even more pills.
And it took him 10 months to find a job,
but he ended up having to take a job on the night shift.
Uh,
and,
and that's a pharmacist.
Lawyers can't find work,
uh,
in America.
So even professionals are having a huge amount of problems.
Absolutely.
It's terrible.
But it's one of these things I worry about the degree to which when we tell
people stuff is really hard,
does it become a self fulfilling prophecy?
You know,
like if you keep telling kids growing up in poor neighborhoods,
and I was a kid who grew up in a poor neighborhood,
so I have some sympathy with this.
But it's,
you know,
if you keep telling people,
well you know,
it's really,
really tough.
It's really hard to get out.
I wonder if partly oh well,
you know,
it's really tough.
So you know,
whatever it is.
Right.
I don't think there's an either or,
but I think there's definitely a bit of that.
But you know,
you kind of disproved it with your example of a pharmacist is looking for 10
months for a job in a very lucrative industry.
Yeah.
So that's sort of disproves it a little bit.
I think you and I are very fortunate in that we can make our money
independently.
We can make a living by doing things on the Internet,
providing content.
And for me doing comedy shows and UFC stuff,
it's,
I don't have to be in the regular job market.
I'm very fortunate because of that.
But for all I ever been in the record and I just drove limos.
I did construction and a lot of things while I was a struggling comedian.
Right,
right.
Okay.
I decided I wanted to be a standup comic at 21 and I sort of abandoned
everything else I was doing and I did a lot of shitty jobs then for a couple of
years.
But before that I taught martial arts.
So I've always had a weird life.
I've always been,
I just knew somehow or another,
um,
I probably,
I probably could have been very different if my life is very different,
but my life wasn't very happy,
you know,
with my parents being divorced and moving across the country and always being
forced,
moved around a lot and always making new friends.
I didn't enjoy school.
I didn't enjoy the experience of going,
I didn't,
I didn't have a desire to learn and I knew that whatever I was going to do it
when it's going to have to be something completely outside of the system,
there was no options for me.
Like the idea of going to like,
some people say,
well you know I really wanted to be a standup comic but you know I'm going to do
it after I passed the bar.
There was none of that.
There's none of that.
It was like this is a job that I actually could do.
Just go and try to do that because a job like be a lawyer,
be a,
you know,
fill in the blank insurance salesman,
whatever the fuck it's going to be.
I can't do it.
I'll go crazy.
Well,
screw plan B,
you know,
Plan B,
everyone says plan B,
but plan B is always going to end up going by the wayside because everything you
do in life,
you strengthen that muscle.
You weaken your other muscles.
So you know,
I will,
I'm a big fan of if you're going to do it,
you know,
do it hard,
do it to do it full on tilt,
Boogie,
you know,
150% and then if you fail at least you won't say,
well I could have done more,
you know,
but,
but just go full.
But then then you can always pick up the pieces,
start something else later.
But Plan B is usually a real disaster.
Like okay,
you can go be an actor.
But the important thing is also you've got that safety net is a news,
a safety net,
isn't it?
I completely agree with you.
And we're going to get attacked for this by people who are unhappy with their
choices in life.
And that's a fact.
You know,
there's,
there's a bunch of people that will say your why family,
she'll,
you know,
Jill,
great idea for you to just go out there and go crazy off people to support you
need to listen.
Stop saying that.
Stop saying any of those things.
Every single person who has ever done anything worthwhile or exceptional or
difficult or extraordinary,
anyone,
whether it's great artists or authors or mathematicians or whatever the fuck it
is.
Everyone encounters difficulties.
There is no easy road.
It does not exist.
It is impossible.
Everyone has issues.
If you have time to pursue a hobby,
if you have time to do anything in your life,
you can better yourself.
And here's one way you never better yourself.
When you come up with excuses for why other people are successful and you're
not,
that shit is fucking dangerous.
When you give yourself an escape.
Yeah,
well that's easy for you to say.
You know you do this,
you do to do it,
and trust me,
every buddy has a hard road.
I wanted to jump out a window several times during my young life.
I wanted to jump in front of a fucking train.
Just end it because it's too much pressure.
Not really,
but you know what I'm saying.
Theoretically,
we all go through hard times.
We all go through depression.
We all do it.
Go through doubt and moments in your life where it's really fucking difficult
and you're trying to figure out what the fuck your path is going to be.
It's hard as shit.
But Stefan and I were talking about this before the podcast starts,
that fat is what makes you a person and those difficult moments are what build
your character.
Show me a great man who's the son of a great man and that's what we're saying.
These kids that are born billionaires,
you're fucked,
you're fucked.
You're never going to be a self made person.
You have a backup trust for your backup,
trust for your trust and your fucked man.
I met a guy like this.
His parents own this gigantic chain of high end stores and they're unbelievably
wealthy.
Billionaire beach in Malibu is this massive community of,
you know,
1520 $30 million homes.
They bought the next door neighbor's homes on both sides and overpaid for them
cause they didn't want anybody staying next to them.
They just bought the homes like $30 million,
$25 million.
They literally own like a hundred houses.
They own homes everywhere.
I'm talking estates in Denver,
in the mountains and you know,
Wyoming,
it's some great ranch.
I mean they just have fucking,
and the guy is a mess.
You could just slap him in the face.
You could just take his pants off.
He would just panic.
He has no confidence.
He's,
he's literally not,
uh,
not a person.
He's like a cat.
He's like a cat and you have to feed or a dog.
It's just,
he's a sad,
sad person.
Resists
since breeds strength.
They muscles and character in,
in,
in mind and on muscles.
Hate to exercise.
That's [inaudible] dot com is an excellent sponsor.
It is,
you know,
that which does not kill us,
makes us stronger.
You know what I mean?
Sort of radiation poisoning is really not good at sort of metaphorically they
out of the pure bio chemistry,
but that,
which is,
it's hard for you is what all the stuff we hate at the time.
It's just stuff that,
that we love later.
You know,
you go like,
wow,
that really did give me an appreciation for this or whatever.
And the Trustafarians,
you know,
like the kids whose parents are really rich.
It is a huge problem among rich parents.
How do you raise your kids?
Because when you're poor or even middle class you,
your kid says,
I want x.
And you said,
what are you saying?
We can't afford it.
Well,
but you have a,
you know,
if your kids looking around and seeing like gold fountains in the living room
and you know,
chocolate bar that's upstairs and so on,
then clearly you can't afford it.
And what do you say to your kids?
It's really,
really tough.
We have to provide limits because of x,
Y and zed.
I mean,
a lot of people like to duck out in the,
we can't afford it excuse,
but rich parents don't have that.
And it's really tough for them to set limits.
It's very hard.
And it's also very hard when a child grows up with no doubt,
if you have no doubt as to what your future is going to be,
you don't have ambition.
The,
a lot of ambition comes from fear.
And,
uh,
as a comic,
some of my best sets ever in standup have come after I bombed.
Like I bombed.
Oh yeah,
look at this.
I've got no career.
We'll also,
it's a terrible feeling.
You don't want to,
you don't want that feeling to,
to reoccur.
So you have these bad sets and then you just get really super motivated to work
on everything that's wrong or recognize what went wrong in that night and never
let it happen again.
And one of the worst traits that a comedian could ever have is to be easily
satisfied with yourself.
It's one of the worst.
If you think you're better than you are or you're really satisfied where
everything,
hey,
it's perfect.
No need to work on it.
It's it.
That's poison.
That's like a terrible,
terrible,
terrible mindset for a standup comedian for that very same reason.
Like it has to be a struggle.
But we always this way,
aren't we?
Like we always dissatisfied with something we achieve,
say shitty and then we're immediately dissatisfied again.
And I,
you know,
there's a lot of people who will promise you piece of mind and Zan and this and
then I actually think that's completely an illusion and I think it actually
contributes to more dissatisfaction.
Dissatisfaction is the nature of the beast.
It's why we're doing this and not going,
Oh God.
Booga Booga in some caves cause we were dissatisfied with the cave.
So we built some hats.
We were dissatisfied with the hats.
We built some condos,
we're always dissatisfied and
therefore we will continue to want to improve things.
That's how things get better at the moment.
We're satisfied with something.
We immediately set a new challenge and remain unsatisfied in the achievement of
that and people who try to end that process.
I think it just trying to end being alive fundamentally.
Mr Manya,
you're talking too much sense here,
sir.
You're confused and we have to break for commercial now free.
We,
I wish we could just to reprogram people's minds back to consumerism.
You're 100% right.
There's,
look,
I think everyone looks forward to this utopian time where whatever motivates
them,
drives them,
freaks them out right now.
Can Be set aside,
the work is done and you can just sort of like watch the sunset over the pond.
And the the,
the problem is this youtube Utopian vision of the future that we have is
probably a carrot that's on a stick that will just never reach and we keep
working hard to improve our society,
our life and ourselves and our families and our relationships.
Hoping that one day we'll achieve this ultimate piece that will never come.
I know.
And,
and this is how people get exploited.
If they can dangle that carrot right and they can say,
well you see the communist into communist utopia,
you won't need to work.
And in the communist utopia or the fascist utopia or you know that Peter Joseph,
robot,
Mommy cities,
you won't have to work and everything will be fine.
Or in the religious view a you'll get to go to heaven or you all achieved
transcendental bliss or you know enough yoga,
you're a button will be firm and your soul,
it would be at peace.
They will get you to give up freedoms and money and so on,
in hopes of buying a piece of mind that is fundamentally anti-human in the long
run.
At the restlessness of our species is the diamond that we get crushed into for
the existence that we currently provide for ourselves in.
Yes,
I agree.
100%.
I think the whole idea about all this is engineering a utopia like Peter Joseph,
who I think is a very smart guy and I like him.
I had him on the podcast.
I enjoy communicating with him.
I think he's very bright.
But what I think is hilarious is that he makes his money as a stockbroker.
I mean he's talking about this utopian world and he's drawing very blood that
keeps him alive from a vampire system.
And this crazy fucking vampire system.
I no,
no,
but he's a,
he's a fan power on the inside.
He's working the inside a system.
So I know he's an inside pamper.
You guys had some serious debates,
didn't you listen to them?
And a couple of flybys,
like I did some reviews of the zeitgeist movies a and um,
and then we actually had a debate.
We have fairly Cordela,
you know,
definitely butted heads.
So which is natural.
This is what kind of what you want.
And then,
um,
yeah,
he did go a little bit,
I thought ballistic and some of the post debate,
uh,
let's say analysis,
where I think he veered off a little bit into ad hominems.
But you know,
my basic point is I don't,
as long as people do two things,
you know,
do two things and you know,
we have friends till the end,
right?
Uh,
respect,
self ownership and you know,
property rights and do not initiate force.
And so look,
if this,
if these cities built by Jack Fresco and his merry of Elvin robots,
if this is human paradise on earth,
I say,
go for it.
Have Fun.
Just don't force people to participate and let people leave as they want.
That's the only thing that matters.
Everything has to be voluntary.
You cannot violate the nonaggression principle.
Everything outside of that is,
you know,
well,
what color drapes do you want?
I don't care.
Just don't steal them.
The Ad Hominems are very disappointing,
aren't they?
You know,
especially when it's just,
you could easily have just disagreed and been fine with that and debated your
points and look,
you and I probably don't agree on everything.
That's probably quite a few things come up that a,
we have different points of view on and that's because we're different human
beings and it's also because there's not a black and white with these ideas of
engineering society.
There's,
it's not a,
there's not a black and white,
it's a very look,
if it was very easy and straight forward,
it would have been done already.
Okay.
It's not,
it's complicated.
There's a lot to being a person.
There's a lot to being a person that contributes to society and there's a lot to
what,
what about society is feeding itself and just feeding more society and more.
What about corporations are just feeding corporations and what about them is
benefiting humanity and if it wouldn't sway it towards benefiting humanity,
it's always the best choice.
But the idea of engineering it and one foolproof way that makes everyone happy.
That's silly that people that want to remove capitalism as a whole.
Like I've met people that have jobs that tell me that people with money are a
problem and I'll go bug.
They can be,
but you know how much money bill gates gives the charities.
Do you know much like charity work that guy does,
how much money he donates to causes that he feels are excellent,
millions and millions and millions and millions of dollars.
There's a great benefit from having that.
That guy being wealthy.
Some people who are rich do a good job with it.
Some people,
but you work to,
everybody works like the person telling me that money's a problem.
Like don't you have a job?
What do you get paid at your job?
They give you free coconuts.
What do they do?
They give you a use of a shower and a place to sleep at night.
Now they give you fucking money,
man.
They give you money.
You just,
you're a capitalist.
You're just not as good a capitalist as that guy is.
It doesn't mean that the system is completely fucked.
It doesn't mean that the idea of this system is completely fucked.
It means it can be fucked.
Yeah,
but it also can be.
It's the choice of the people that control it.
If all of the world bankers got together today and did acid and they realize,
oh my God,
guys,
we are fucking up.
We're D,
we're creating all this drunk,
we're going to die anyway.
Listen,
if we just pooled our money together into these massive charities to re
engineer,
says societies and put money into poor communities and stop causing war and stop
extracting natural resources out of these places for massive profit and and
massive loss of human life,
if that just happened,
the entire world would change instantly and they'd literally have the power to
do that.
They would just have to all come to some sort of an agreement.
But there's no,
yeah.
And look,
charity is important,
and I'm not a Republican,
but one thing that is statistically true is that Republicans give a lot more to
charity than Democrats do,
which is why Democrats believe that welfare programs that are needed because
fundamentally stingy bastards who don't give anything,
they feel everybody needs to be forced to do it.
Is it that they're have less money?
Is it per capita?
Like if you look at the Democrats per capita versus Republicans per capita?
I don't know about that,
but I do know that the Democrat donations tend to be far larger to the Democrat
Party.
I mean,
Democrats,
uh,
get their money from,
you know,
celebrities from,
they have these,
you know,
$5 billion plate dinners,
whatever for Barack Obama.
And whereas the average donation to the Republican Party is like 20 bucks.
But the real,
the Democrats get their money from unions.
Uh,
and I'd like to talk a little bit about unions and mixed martial arts,
but we'll get back.
Sure.
Okay.
I think that's a really interesting topic.
Fascinating topic.
So yeah,
Democrats get their money from,
from forced union dues and from celebrities and from the entertainment business
and so on.
And uh,
they,
they're just generally not very generous with regards to local charity has a lot
to do with their secularism,
right?
Because a lot of the charitable donations come out of religiosity,
but there's no guarantee that charity is the solution.
There's lots of economists who think that Bill Gates would be doing much better,
good for the world if we'd stayed on at Microsoft and built that a company to be
even more successful and bigger with more employees and so on,
that that would be generating more value to society than giving money.
You know,
if you look at India and China,
just over the last 20 years,
it has been the biggest poverty reduction in the history of the known universe.
I mean,
it really can't be overemphasized.
Literally hundreds of millions of people have come out of poverty in India.
It's 50,000 families a month are getting into the middle class out of,
out of poverty because they just got rid of socialist policies and let people
actually trade and make money and start their businesses.
They cut the red tape and all the licensing requirements and so on.
And of course in,
in China,
they were less totalitarian communist assholes and actually became some
reasonable free trade guys.
And out of that process,
more people that come out of poverty in the 20 years that they've stopped
interfering with people's trading abilities than an entire century of western
aid to,
to third world countries.
So I don't know whether it's getting out of people's way,
uh,
in terms of letting them do what they want to do and build their businesses or
whether it's giving them lots of money.
It's a balance between the two.
But I don't know if charity is always the answer.
I think just getting out of people's way is a great way to let them,
uh,
like what is it in California?
Do you need like 27 permits to open a lemonade stand or something like that?
I mean if you stop doing that kind of stuff or you don't need 300 hours to
become a hair braider on a beach of training to get a license,
just let people do their own thing and let the customer be a decider about
what's valuable,
what's safe,
what's right,
what's wrong.
Then I think you do a lot more for poverty in many ways.
There are some people who need charity,
but I think most times people just need people out of the way so that they can
go and create their own opportunities.
That's true for the most part in a lot of ways,
but I think that it's hard to undermine what Bill Gates has done for people that
can't afford things.
You know what he's done as far as providing funds for education and a lot of the
charitable work that they've done.
I know if that
would all get,
have get gotten done if he stayed on at Microsoft and made it bigger and better
and no,
that wasn't it.
But other things would have,
like Microsoft would have grown,
would've have added shareholder value to people who then would have donated some
of that to charity.
He wouldn't created more jobs.
He also would have opened up more uh,
overseas offices in African,
so much with a hired people.
And so that would have been more sustaining.
And again,
it's not to say there's no place for charity at all,
but the,
the balance between charity and opportunity on how to deal with poverty.
You know,
you had charity all through the dark ages,
all through the Middle Ages.
People gave money to the church and the church had a,
you know,
indigent houses for the poor.
It didn't solve the problem of poverty and that was solved by,
you know,
free markets and property rights and free trade and all that kind of stuff that
solve the problem of poverty through that wealth.
You get a charitable opportunities that weren't there before.
But fundamentally I think charity is a nice side dish to opportunity.
It's important,
but I think if we think the charity is going to create that wealth,
all it does is transfer.
And usually it's to a onetime use.
The nice thing with the entrepreneurial stuff,
it creates self sustaining and self growing economic opportunities.
You know the old thing,
give them an official,
you know,
he'll vote for you forever or teach a man to fish and uh,
he'll become a republican.
I don't exactly know how that car stayed teaching people in that sense though,
they providing a,
a possibility for education that maybe wouldn't have existed for a lot of poor
people.
So in that sense they are teaching people that education is important,
but education when you don't have a lot of economic opportunities.
Like if you look at Africa,
Africa is one of the few places in the 20th century,
like over the last 50 years,
it's declined in,
in net standard of living.
I mean it's wretched.
I mean South African and how thick the rape capital of the world,
which you won't see on a lot of brochures.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's just unbelievable.
The crime rates and so on like a,
if you rent a car in South Africa,
they actually have a fire that comes out the side to declare a carriage accurate
so you can push a button and have like little jets of flame to come out to push
carjackers back.
And the amount of charity that's been applied in Africa is absolutely huge.
But generally it goes government to government,
right?
So you give a bunch of money to a bunch of corrupt South African dictators and
then you sell them a whole bunch of arms and then you wonder why there's not a
lot of freedom for the general population.
I think if you can scale back that,
I mean Africans would do fine as well as everyone else if they had the same
economic opportunities,
give people a bunch of education and you still have a very corrupt and fascistic
style of government.
I'm not sure what they can really do with that education other than joined the
civil service,
which seems to happen quite a bit.
So I'm a big one for like scale back interference in the market.
People will create their own opportunities.
Uh,
you know,
the last say fair,
let them alone,
let them trade,
let them build their own wealth and all that kind of stuff that really is
inhibited.
Charity will help people stuck in the sort of hardening amber of fascist,
monstrous governments.
And that's needed for the people who are stuck there.
But I think the longterm solution has to be to try and find a way to try it.
Like let me give you one other hopefully not too boring example,
which is a,
uh,
subsidies for agriculture,
AH,
ratchet for the third world.
Unbelievably disruptive for the Third World because you know,
you give all these subsidies
to farmers and the farmers then grow too much crap.
Uh,
and then what did they do?
They dump it in the third world,
which destroys the market for local farmers.
And you give all this food to the government,
the government then hands it out to people they like and don't hand it out to
people they don't like.
That's reinforcing their power.
And then there's no local farming left cause you,
so just one of these kinds of examples.
If we stop screwing up their economies,
uh,
by selling arms,
by dumping,
uh,
food,
on their markets and all that.
And even the foreign aid happens with that too.
I think they do fine,
but it's a lot easier to throw money at a problem than to actually try and deal
with these immensely corrupt governments.
That's a really unknown but creepy aspect of the United States agriculture
system is this,
this subsidies which causes people to grow food that they're not even gonna use
causes people to like to,
to,
to profit from corn and,
and to,
to put a lot of effort and emphasis into things that they know that they're
going to get subsidies from.
It's a real strange sort of power circle.
It goes on.
What it does to people's health is wretched.
Like,
yeah,
there's this tiny sugar industry in the United States,
very concentrated economic force.
They get millions and millions and millions of dollars in subsidies and they
been trying to cut this for years,
but everybody,
you know,
lobby and focus their efforts.
Right?
And so what happened is when the subsidies,
when,
uh,
when the tariffs,
the taxes on imports or sugar went way up in the 70s,
what did people,
it's not doing,
they said,
wow,
sugar in America is really expensive.
What are we going to switch to?
High Fructose Corn Syrup.
And yeah,
again,
I'm no nutritionists,
but that seemed to be quite a lot of people out there who think that high
fructose corn syrup has a lot to do with,
uh,
the,
the growing weight problem in the United States.
A along with,
of course,
the fact that you've got,
you know,
dairy farmers and wheat farmers and so on,
lobbying the government to create these horrible food pyramids where they say,
well,
low fat is really important.
And then what do they do?
Because if you take fat out of stuff and sure,
Grad staff,
it takes like cardboard.
They take the fat out of the stuff that's in the grocery store and they put
sugar or high fructose corn syrup in instead.
And then people are like,
wow,
I guess this does taste good.
Like I was at breakfast this morning.
I picked up a yogurt.
It says low fat,
right,
and what's the second ingredient is high fructose corn syrup.
It's like,
that is not going to be,
I don't give me the fat.
I'll take,
I'll eat a salad,
shove a whole stick of butter up my nose rather than put that stuff into my
systems.
Some fat is actually important.
Yeah,
you need it for your brain.
You need it for like lots of good stuff.
Essential fatty acids.
They're very important for your life.
Where are you going to store your LSD?
Exactly.
If you don't have the fat,
then you're in a business meeting.
How attending goal is going to come out of people's eyeballs 20 years from now.
You need to play it.
You need a suitcase for that state.
I think that's a fat myth.
I don't know.
We're just,
you agree for excuse to get out of work and I saw an octopus.
It's right.
I'm having a flashback,
man.
That's why I was so creative the last quarter.
When you start talking about economics and you start talking about giving
businesses more freedom,
people get real nervous because people think of businesses as being these
monsters that they get power and then they just start trampling and stealing
things.
It's like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
What are you growing over there?
What are you growing?
I've grown with a robot.
Monster is going to eat the world.
Oh,
come on man,
you gotta jump through government hoops and loops.
Seen a futuristic,
scientific,
a science fiction movie with a negative portrayal of a corporation.
Come on the nebulance.
So wonderful.
So then awesome corporation,
maybe big corporations.
Okay.
Oh God.
I'm going to bore your listeners with econ one on one,
but okay.
Cooperations are state created.
Horrible semi fascistic stick monstrous.
They do not exist in the free market.
Cooperation has nothing to do with the free market.
You know,
we may start a business together and all that in the free market.
It's like,
okay,
you started a business,
you don't get this legal shield.
You don't get to take profits out of the corporation when it makes money.
And then if it loses money,
you don't ever have to put anything back.
You don't have this thing where if the corporation or if you do something
illegal,
the corporation can,
can get sued or I can get fined and so on.
It's a shield that is created to protect the people in charge of the
corporations because they give a lot of money to a,
to politicians.
Barack Obama's the only reason he's in power as he took huge amounts of money
from the financial sector.
Uh,
more so than anyone else.
Cause you don't really see this really talked about.
But this is why the bailout and all of this happened,
uh,
particularly under his watch,
the tarp and all of that stuff,
which was started under Bush,
but it's expanded under Obama.
Cooperation's did not exist until quite recently.
And in the past,
if you were the head of a,
uh,
a trading company and you're trading company lost money,
you could lose your house.
You could,
like,
you could,
that people could come after your personal assets.
So these guys were really careful about their investments one day.
So they got this legal shield,
you know,
hey,
the corporation makes 1 billion bucks.
I can take that money out of the corporation and now it's mine.
And if I then do something wrong in the corporation,
loses 1 billion bucks,
too bad shareholders and employees pay the price.
I mean,
it's a wretched,
unfair system that has nothing to do with the free market.
Of course,
the government over say the corporations of the problem to deflect,
uh,
you know,
what's really going on,
which is the corporate shield and the reasons why they gave this was a,
to get the money from the corporate owners and B,
because then they get to tax corporations.
And then everyone somehow thinks that there's this thing called the corporation,
like this blimp floating around the universe that you can tax for free.
Like they did this fine recently,
$900 million,
uh,
on some financial entity for Ritz,
wrong wrongdoings or whatever.
When people are like,
yeah,
you know,
they find that cooperation.
Like somehow the corporation is paying,
there's no corporation.
What happens is the shareholders end up paying,
the employees don't get raises.
The customers end up with service fees.
I mean there was no cooperation to tax.
It's only people.
So anyway,
minor rant.
But the corporations,
they're just,
they're part of,
of the state a state capitalism or what's sometimes called crap adultism,
which is just the government and,
and corporations working together.
Technically that's fascism,
but it doesn't have anything to do with the free market.
It's just the modern bloated monstrosity that's been created.
And it's just people figuring out a way to extract money and manipulating the
system to make it easier for them to extract money.
You Heather,
it's extracting money from taxes or whether it's extracting money in the form of
political donations,
however,
the finger on a way to do it.
And what gets crazy about it is that there's a bunch of human beings that are a
part of this thing that really isn't looking out for human beings.
I mean,
it's some people profit,
you get money from it.
But if you look at the ultimate destruction of these things,
like very often they're not looking out for people.
And outlook.
I say this as a an insider.
I mean I,
I started a company with my brother in the 90s.
We grew this company,
we'd sold it to them.
We went public.
And the process of going public is like having cocaine injected into your dick
being lashed into a barrel full of psychotic monkeys and thrown off a cliff.
Uh,
it's,
it's completely insane.
You,
you go mental,
you focused on the stock price rather than building longterm value.
And you can make a fortune from tiny upticks and down ticks in the stock price
rather than focusing on satisfying your co,
it really draws your attention away.
You know,
it's like you're,
you're chatting with your wife and some incredibly stacked woman in a bikini
goes by and you don't have your sunglasses on to pretend that you're still
staring at her.
Even if you do,
they'll lift your sunglasses.
That's right.
And it's like mad dog docs are like continually having these incredible looking
women go by while you're trying to focus on the love of your life.
And it's like,
you know,
your hormones are going one way and your,
your heart is going another.
It's completely insane.
It really warps your thinking.
And this is why corporations have given up on r and d have,
can focus entirely on marketing and stock pitches because the amount of money
you can make is insane.
And it's because so many people's money is being forced into the stock market.
I mean,
it's like herding a bunch of sheep off a cliff and saying,
well,
those sheep seem to be kind of suicidal now,
don't they?
It's like,
no,
it's because like you got to your 401k plan.
What happens if you don't put money in your four one k government takes it,
right?
What happens if you don't invest in various institutes?
Like if,
if,
if your money gets taken from a union,
the union has to invest it in your pension plans and all of that.
Unions have a huge amount of say in what happens in the stock market.
Who wants to be in the stock market?
I don't want to be in the stock market.
Maybe you do because you were,
you thrilled junkie and all that.
But I don't want to be,
I don't want to be in the stock market.
I really,
really,
the stock market is for people who know what they're doing.
I don't want to be in the stock market.
Nobody I know wants to be in the stock market,
but we all have to be in the stock market because it's like,
it's like that old joke where in Scotland,
right?
Scotland,
Scottish people are supposed to be cheap.
That's a stereotype when I grew up.
And so,
you know,
an English men and a Scotsman and walking down and uh,
a,
a thief comes up and says,
I'm going to rob you of everything.
You've got this to tie some intensive English guy and says,
Hey,
he is that 20 quid that I oh yeah.
You know,
cause it's like you're going to lose the money so you give it,
you know,
give it to the,
so the government's going to take your money by force or you give it to a bunch
of parasitical three I'd wrote faced stockbrokers.
Right.
It's,
it's like,
okay,
give it to the stockbrokers.
You know,
if the guy's gonna steal my money,
I'll put it on red 22 and that's how the stock market works.
So there's way too much money in the stock market.
There should be like 1% of the money that's in the stock market that's there
now.
So you've got these massive tsunamis of cash rolling back and forth.
You gave me a good coffee here.
I just want to mention that caveman coffee,
how to my friend tape.
So I'm going to do three more rants and then faceplant
April,
you're going to hang in there because that's got MCT oil and butter.
So it's going to,
you're going to hang in there.
It's going to have a lot more than that.
You going to have a really strange shit in the morning.
Maybe that'll help me.
Something nice and s shaped.
It's going to be like the subtitle.
It's going to be the subtitles to some Japanese movie that's going to be in the
day.
It's going to be like if you stuck mud in a musket and then just pull that pin
back and boom.
Where'd it go?
All right,
well,
so yeah,
I mean just,
just way too much money of the stock market and corporations are,
are,
are taking moral and financial and legal responsibility away from it.
So executive,
so this is just natural.
You know,
you,
you know,
you drug a ballerina,
you get a weird show,
but it's not the ballerina.
It's just what happens,
right?
That's a very fun expression.
You drug a ballerina,
you get a weird show.
That should be,
there should be a photo of you like this Internet meme and it just says you drug
a ballerina.
You get a weird show,
Stefan.
Molyneux that's so true.
It's a great way of putting it.
And I think what a lot of what you're bitching about and we're,
we're,
we're both bitching about is,
um,
it comes down to a couple of things.
It comes down to a human beings being born into a system that's already fucked
up and comes down to managing your own thinking as well.
Figure out how to a way,
you as an individual who has allegedly,
and it's another debate,
has free will.
That's a huge debate.
The freewill debate,
which is very esoteric and strange.
I don't know.
I can't,
I'm not qualified.
I would,
I would like to have you and Sam Harris discuss the,
the freewill debate.
I agree and disagree with,
with both sides.
So I don't know,
uh,
I don't know what's correct and what's not when it comes to,
I would do that,
but only if you would call it like a,
um,
mixed martial arts fight.
That would be the LGBT thing.
And if the chilkat there'll be very distracting.
I thought,
you know,
this debate would go way better if we had a choke out option because at the end
of it,
you can just press a button and both of you get down to your shorts and just
start duking it out.
Yeah.
That's great.
That's just the threat of that is what keeps people gentlemen,
Lee actually,
you know,
when,
when people know that there will be no physical violence,
they can get very squirrely.
You know,
people can get very mouthy.
Again,
I don't want to keep harping on rich kids,
but have you ever been around like a really spoiled rich kid that likes to yell
at people that are working,
yell at security or yell?
I have a friend who does security and a,
there's a,
a famous person I won't name,
but her name rhymes with Paris Hilton and she was out and she got shitty with my
friend who is essentially,
he's a killer.
He's a,
I mean he's,
he's not working security cause he's a cutie pie.
He's working security cause he understands how to keep people secure so he knows
how to deal with threats.
He knows how to deal with violence.
Okay.
And you guys disassembling people and some person is just shitting on them.
That's remarkably similar to Paris.
Hilton might not have been Paris,
Hilton,
whatever,
whatever.
But I mean why would she get away with that?
Why would anybody,
why would anybody think they can get away with,
it's because they know the threat of violence doesn't exist.
And you know as well Joe,
that there's a huge tendency that
people have to mistake accidents of birth for personal virtues.
Yes.
They're all saying like you think that you hit a triple but you were born on
third base.
So people who are rich,
they think,
well I'm,
I'm better than above the born rich.
You didn't earn that.
And like this guy in my high school,
his father I think was running the Toronto Stock Exchange or whatever.
And you know,
I was Linda,
this little tiny apartment with my mom and my brother and you know,
it's like the matriarchal manners.
It was all like that to do the fallout from like the 60s and seventies feminist
revolution.
Divorce rate was through the roof and it was all the single Manville like the,
the girlfriend farm for the fatigue industry.
And we went over to this guy's place to rehearse and play.
We were working on it.
It was just,
it went on forever.
And you know,
these are the kids,
16,
you know,
they get their a,
they get their sports car and that they show up in school and everyone is like
oohing and aahing and these guys are printing and I get it.
There are 16,
what did they know?
Right?
What did I know when I was 16 but that's just an accident.
You know,
he just happened to be born there,
you know,
like it wasn't like you,
you laser targeted from the stalk army and decided to go to that house rather
than some other places,
you know,
like you're not a guided missile of wise,
a pre prenatal aiming.
And so I,
we all have that,
you know,
and it's true people who are born pretty or people who are born rich or you
know,
people guys,
sometimes we'll just born tall or flags or,
or you know,
like I was told when I was a kid,
uh,
if effort,
manageability,
you'd be an a plus,
you know,
like I just wasn't trying hard enough.
It wasn't the school's fault.
It wasn't my family's fault.
It wasn't a chaotic or crazy situation where it's growing up.
And we weren't poor.
We did,
I didn't have to have three jobs.
I just needed to work a little harder like the other kids did who had good homes
and all that.
It's natural and,
and we have a very tough time really getting how much our environment has to do
with who we become.
Absolutely.
Because that gives you a lot of humility.
Like,
okay,
I was born with a fairly good brain and you know,
fairly good language center.
I try to use that for as much good as I can.
But with all the humility of knowing that,
you know,
I mean if,
if I'd been hit the wrong way with a ball when I was a kid,
I'd be a whole different person.
Uh,
if I'd been born,
as you said,
you know,
different race,
a different country,
different culture.
I mean,
you know,
not a lot of female playwrights in Iran,
because it's just bad luck.
Sorry.
You know,
you really drew the short Straw.
We have a very tough time and I think that basic humanity that we have is,
is diminishing and it's catastrophic and it's diminishing largely because of
single moms because wow.
The,
the statistic is that by far the best predictor waving this pennant.
You like trying to talk about empathy.
Let me just do my thing.
The best predictor of for the growth of empathy and a human being is the close
presence of a father.
Uh,
and this is something that's kind of a no,
cause we all think that moms are about the um,
uh,
the nurturing and the emotional development someone.
But statistically,
you know,
uh,
an outside unstructured play plus the presence of a dad is the biggest thing of
developing empathy.
You take father's out of the equation and society,
this is rice.
Sociopathy has doubled over the last 15 years.
This is basically why we have a welfare is the destruction of
the family.
There's not a welfare state.
It's a single mother state.
It's all making up for not having a provider.
Well,
the problem with phrasing it like that though is you say that the issue is
single mothers,
but the issue is really that the father isn't around whether or not it was the
mother's fault of the father's fault,
whoever's fault it was at that relationship didn't work out.
Whether it's mutual or one person has the majority of the blame,
it's that the family's broken up.
It's not that the single mom,
it's just that family's broken.
Maybe it's like,
so I think we're about the same age.
Is that right?
46.
I'm 47 so,
uh,
we got a younger person in the room.
Yeah,
Jamie's 21 Jamie.
I didn't know some Italian kids who had that kind of growth phase where the
weird ones.
Yeah.
The ones who have to shave the back of their knuckles.
Like after they turned 10.
That's my Rachel,
Here's your,
and here's your finger shaver.
Now that you're 10.
Yeah.
Okay.
So in your general,
how old are you?
31.
I just turned yesterday.
Okay,
so have your birthday,
sweetie.
You're really happy birthday.
Um,
who asks who out?
It's a women ask men out.
Is it mutual man ask.
This is a completely broad ended question and it depends entirely on the game of
set individuals.
I know,
but generally,
I mean in general,
generally guys,
that's the girls ask Ben out.
They don't have to.
Okay.
But okay,
so,
so then we can't say that single moms is equally shared because the single mom,
like men proposed women dispose,
right?
I mean men say I want to update you or have sex with you.
It sounds like something Al Sharpton would say.
It does rhyme.
Yeah.
I'm afraid I don't have that to Atlanta.
We propose women dispose.
Yeah.
You mean by that?
Well,
so men say,
I want to date you are on at Saks with you.
I want to go out with you.
And the women say yes or no.
Well,
men are generally more aggressive and women are generally more desirable.
So that makes us have to go after them.
May possibly figure that out.
Right.
I mean of course women are more desirable to us,
but you know,
two lesbians,
no wait,
that doesn't maybe show more than even to them.
They just,
they just whatever reason,
can't figure out what women see in us at all.
Like I just,
I,
I fundamentally like intellectually maybe I think that that men have a lot of
value in relationships,
but you know,
we are 40 were smelly.
Uh,
we sit at odd angles,
we don't cross her legs.
So we,
you know,
we rarely use Napkins and I,
I,
I cannot understand why we need like 10 times more pillows then people on the
bed I like during the day when it's,
anyway,
these are things that confusing to me,
but,
but fundamentally women say yes or no to,
to relationships.
So they do get to choose who the man is a lot more than the man gets to choose
who the woman is.
Oh,
I don't know about that.
I don't agree with that.
I think that ultimately it boils down to once you finally meet each other,
do you like each other?
And if the woman likes a man,
as much as the man likes a woman,
it works out.
And if they don't,
then it becomes this weird balance of power,
this weird shifting sort of a thing.
But I think there's a lot of men that don't want in a relationship and they end
it or you know,
they pursue and they ended.
I think it's probably,
I don't want to be a 50,
50,
I don't want to give
you a statistic,
but I would say there's a good number of men who ate and relationships and a
good number of women who are in relationships to put all the power and the
women's side is,
I think not all of course say we disagree on stuff.
We found one,
but we have facts to,
to mediate.
So statistically,
uh,
it's,
it depends on how you measure it,
but that 70 to 80% of marriages are ended by women.
Is that true?
Or is it the men are so fucking Douchey that the women have no choice,
that the men have given up a long time ago and they just don't want to fucking
bother going to the court.
So just to shut the fuck up,
I'm going to go out and they shut the door and then the woman calls the lawyer
and while the woman ended that relationship,
did she or was it mutual?
Just one person decided to make the call to the lawyer.
But did they guy already give up to the point where he was just treating her
like shit,
hoping she would leave?
It's like the old Sam Kinison joke about marriage.
He goes,
you know,
he goes,
uh,
I don't like to bring up women.
So what I do is I just stay up all night,
do kg for four or five days.
I come home drunk and smelling like pussy until you get to a point where she
leaves you right,
she leaves you cause you're falling apart.
And he goes,
hey,
here's the best part.
She feels like shit.
She left.
I was at my lowest ebb honey.
And then you just,
it could have been there for me.
We keep it a successful team together.
Pitches on both sides.
I agree with that,
but I don't see any behavior.
I don't think that we give,
I don't think we give women enough responsibility in this area.
I think that men generally wanting to protect women.
I think that men generally,
oh,
that's crazy.
And I don't agree with that at all.
You don't think men want to call them?
They want to protect the ones that they love.
But the reason why so many women get sexually assaulted isn't because so many
men want to protect them.
Men want to fuck,
you know,
and they want to then when they get a girl that they like to fuck,
they want to hold onto and make sure nobody else hurts her.
You know?
I mean that's the ape shit,
you know,
that's the worst aspects of people.
But the idea that men want to generally protect women sure is less than they
want to generally protect themselves though,
you know,
and I think less than less than really would be ideal.
If you look at the balance of power between men and women,
the real issue is the physical strength.
The real issue is that men can physically do things to women.
Like where,
where does rape come from?
Where does the violence against women comes from?
It comes from people that are,
that are capable of committing violence against women and rape.
You know,
like a woman like Rhonda Rousey,
UFC champion,
it doesn't have to worry about some hundred pound due to smoke cigarettes.
You know what I'm saying?
She literally doesn't have to,
she'd be in the room with him and you know,
he'd be like,
Bitch,
I'm gonna rape you.
Oh really?
Well,
boom.
Drop him on his head.
And He'd be unconscious.
I mean,
she'd break his arm off.
That's,
that's a physical situation that women have to deal with that men don't.
And I think for sure we could do a way better job of addressing that.
And I think,
you know,
like this one,
the Steubenville rape case,
you know,
this case in Ohio,
this case remind bunches,
football players got to get her high school football players got some underage
girl drunk,
raped her,
and then the guys went to jail and they just got out.
Um,
why is that?
Why is it so horrible?
Well,
here's what's so horrible about it.
It was a girl.
It was men that did it to a girl.
If it was a bunch of women who raped a guy,
they got him drunk and sucked his dick for an hour and a half,
everyone would be laughing about it.
Okay.
It's a sexual act that happens to a woman who can't control himself,
and then you find out that it's a football player group,
a group of giant athletes,
a group of superstrong men who obviously could have physically dominated her as
well.
It becomes a horrific act if you simply reverse the sexist,
it becomes a comedy.
If it's some nerd who gets too drunk in a sorority and they all fuck him for
three or four hours and take pictures of his penis.
It's a comedy.
But because it's a woman,
it's a tragedy.
And the reason why it's a tragedies because men are physically stronger.
It's really that simple.
So the idea that I think that men want to physically protect women,
man,
there's a lot of evidence that they don't.
You know,
I think it's a giant,
broad generalization.
I think the nicest men certainly do.
I think I would certainly,
if I was seeing a woman that was being physically assaulted or something,
I would absolutely risk my health to help her.
I wouldn't be able to live with myself if I didn't,
especially if I cared about her.
Right.
Some people get on your training too,
right?
I mean,
you,
you know how to do this.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's also part of it is I know that I have some preparation in that area,
which is a very terrifying thing for people who don't,
you know,
I've seen people involved in physical altercations who don't know how to defend
themselves.
And it becomes like you're facing a werewolf.
It becomes like the most horrific thing in the world.
Cause you're going to get slaughtered and you know,
you're going to get slaughtered and people hyperventilate.
They don't know how to deal with the stress.
That's,
I think you're doing yourself a disservice as a human being if you don't know
how to defend yourself a little bit.
And you're a man.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
So a lot of points,
maybe,
perhaps two minutes,
you know,
uh,
who gets raped for more men or women in America?
Men Do.
But here's the problem.
That statistic,
they're getting raped by men.
So even though men get raped more,
So men are still the fucking problem.
Men are just raping.
They're raping men and they're raping women.
Yeah,
they raped men more.
But that's just because we keep them pinned up with men.
If we had no prisons and everyone ran free and we just fucking slaughtered
people that,
that we are absolutely sure don't contribute to society,
whether they're murderers or rapists,
we just slaughtered them.
We would have the rape stuff would pretty much die off.
It's keeping men together,
locked in a box and making them fuck each other.
Yeah.
But it's a man doing the real problem with that.
You know,
that's the,
the MRA argument against feminism is that men actually get rate more than women,
but by men.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's still a shitty argument.
Well,
it's not,
I think it's not an argument against feminism.
I think what it is is not something that people generally know and like for
instance,
like pretty common knowledge.
Most of you know,
I was surprised.
Again,
certainly no gauge of everyone.
Also,
as you probably know,
like 96 97,
98% of workplace deaths are male and all that kind of stuff.
Right?
Or so I think,
or the fact that 50% of domestic violence,
um,
recipients a are men,
right?
And men being battered and they're actually,
you get that
no men's battered shelters you actually can't get,
you can't get security.
You can't get this American son.
We don't defend pussies.
Chicks are kicking your ass.
I say that not just a,
one of my favorite people ever was murdered by his wife,
Phil Hartman.
Oh yeah.
Fellow.
A Toronto native,
brilliant,
brilliant comedian.
And a,
I knew both of them very well.
I knew him and I knew her and it was a horrific scene and very,
very tragic.
And if you,
you know,
if you know someone like that,
you know that it is possible for a woman to do it to a man just like it's
possible for a man to do it with a woman.
There's weapons,
ladies and gentlemen,
there's knives and there's guns and ever sleep sometimes.
And by the way,
you know that that's there.
There's good and bad in that.
The good in that is that you can defend yourself against a man.
If someone is,
if you're a woman and you're physically weak,
but you have a gun,
you can say,
get the fuck out of my house and the guy has to run away because you have a gun.
There's good in that.
But there's also,
you know,
people,
people do horrible things.
They get angry at each other and it happens with both sexes,
with men and with women.
It's,
there's,
there's no need to generalize.
It's,
it's all just shitty people.
It's all just shitty people and shitty circumstances and a gigantic past of
momentum,
of terrible decision making.
It's led you to this really unstable state,
current state that you find yourself in.
And then you add drugs and you add antidepressants.
You know,
I mean I believe you and I discussed this the last time we talked,
but the amount of fucking school shooters that are on antidepressants like
causation does not real.
You know,
people want to pretend there's not like a relation between those two.
The FDA disagree.
The FDA has black wanting the strongest warning labels on this stuff.
Causes suicidal ideation,
causes homicidal rage courses.
I mean on some people.
Yeah,
some people,
that's what we have to realize.
It's like it's not a black and white thing.
It's some people die from fucking peanuts.
Okay.
Some people can't pet a dog or they go into a hyper ventilating shock.
I mean some people literally around dogs,
their,
their throat will constrict and they can't breathe.
Massively allergic to Dander cat,
same thing.
People are all people are different.
A lot of people are allergic to weird shit and but a lot of people also could
benefit from being healthier.
We,
this is one of the things we discussed before the podcast started.
How many people that take an antidepressant could have fixed their problem just
with a little exercise and diet change with a little,
just getting around better people,
having a better relationship,
being a friendlier person,
trying to exercise the stress out of your life,
both mentally and physically.
And then let's see what kind of emotional and psychological state you're in
because the idea that this,
we need a holistic approach to the human organism and that holistic approach
should really have a big impact in what kind of medication we subscribe to
people.
I think it should have a massive impact.
And if you find someone and the person is eating fucking donuts all day and you
know they sleep four hours a night,
the constantly drinking red bulls and the depressed,
Huh,
okay,
we've got to fix this first.
Do they're a smart person,
underachieving in some dead end job and they don't have people around them
saying,
listen man,
you've got more to offer the world.
Let's just find a way to get you out of the hamster wheel and get Johnson some
flat track.
The dead end job,
dead end lives,
dead end relationships.
Almost just as bad as some physical amma ailment.
You mean the literally do suck the fucking life out of you?
We've all experienced it to some degree if we've,
if we're lucky because it makes us appreciate the good times when you do a
experience,
something along those lines,
but I think that man,
you got to really deal with that first before anything else and there's too many
people in this world that want a pill.
They just want to fix things.
And I've said this before,
but I'd have to say it again just in the interest of clarity.
This is coming from a person who I know several people who have benefited
tremendously from antidepressants is not a black and white thing.
It's not either or.
There is a lot of variables when it comes to antidepressants,
when it comes to medication,
when it comes to mental health,
there's a lot of variables and we've done some amazing things to help a lot of
people that have really had real issues,
but we've got to figure out who the fuck actually has issues and who doesn't.
And what the statistic that you brought up before the podcast was over 41 out of
four women on antidepressants.
Yeah.
In America I think.
Yes,
the 35 or 40 and over one out of four women on antidepressants and those that
just the people who've gone and gotten diagnosed.
Right.
Lots of other,
yeah.
I mean there is,
there's a lot of good things that are happening I think in the world with
regards to human relationships.
I think that we are getting smarter.
I think we are getting more positive.
I think that we are getting,
dare I use the hackneyed Victorian term,
more virtuous bedroom in our relationships.
You know,
there's an awareness of of beating and emotional abuse and all.
I think that the standards are kind of raising right.
You know,
Dr Phil is like the number one daytime show and he talks a lot about,
you know,
how to be reasonably decent human beings in relationships,
which is sad that he has to keep saying that,
you know,
like stop screaming at each other and stuff,
hitting each other stuff,
doing trunk stuff,
you know,
the jail Doctor Phil to figure out your fucking life.
You're you're way behind the ball.
There's a lot of other shit you need to cover.
Right.
But so I think a lot of that stuff has been going really well,
but I think there's a lot of stuff that is not,
not going so well.
So.
Well,
I mean a lot of,
you know,
just basic things.
You were talking the other day about breastfeeding,
I remember you,
you were looking up on the uh,
look,
looking up on the website.
No,
I just take the first website and that's,
that's how it works.
That's true.
That's the way it works.
That's how you do anything that disagrees with us.
I mean,
it's just overkill to go to the second one.
That makes so much work.
Wouldn't it be first if it wasn't right,
that's,
that's the key thing.
But so yeah,
I mean like 30%.
She was saying 30% of women still are only breastfeeding for the minimum minimum
amount of time,
six minutes,
six months.
Um,
I was,
uh,
this guy,
Steven pinker I think would be,
if you can get him on,
he's a really smart guy,
great to talk to 'em but uh,
he's a,
I think he's a neurobiologist neuroscientist.
He's um,
uh,
and,
and he basically was,
there's a lot of studies out there that say that they are sort of personality
traits go like 50% genetic and maybe they can get zero to 10% is the parents and
the rest of it is kind of cultural and so on.
Right.
And you know,
I'm not going to argue with the science,
I'm not a scientist,
but I will say that I think that parents don't have really that much involvement
in kids' lives from a guidance standpoint that much anymore.
I read this statistic the other day that said,
the average dad has like 20 minutes of conversation with his children every
week.
Whoa.
Average.
Right.
And so,
and,
and that,
and that just,
that's of the people who are present.
That doesn't count.
The dads were absent.
And someone,
because you know,
the typical,
you know,
two family working,
I mean,
what's their day like?
I've seen it,
I've seen it up close and this is one of the reasons I kept wanting to have kids
because I saw what happened.
You know,
you get up at six o'clock in the morning,
you've got to get your kids up breakfast,
get them out of the school bus,
you go to your work all day,
you're sweating bullets to get pick 'em up,
uh,
the day after school daycare or wherever they are,
get them home,
feed them,
do homework,
you're bathe them,
you know,
get them to bed and then you start the whole thing again.
It's all just her management.
It's all just keep them going through the,
the,
the maze and all that.
And I think that,
um,
like I've been a stay at home dad,
my daughter is five now and there's a lot of little guidance things that
happened during the week about how to modify,
you know,
where they're going to help to help them understand sharing or empathy or
understanding how to do when,
when negotiations rather than just focus on what they want,
which is natural for little kids,
but it's all these tiny little corrections that are scattered throughout the
week.
You can,
you don't know when they're going to be a,
but you have to kind of be around for them.
And I think that we don't really have much opportunity for Martin parents to
really stay involved.
Like we kind of designed as a species to be around our parents.
You know,
they were there when the fields,
the dads would take them,
you went hunting recently,
dads would take them out hunting and stuff like that.
And that's when you have your conversations and you teach the kids the values
and all that kind of stuff.
It's really been supplanted by government,
by daycare,
government schools and all of that.
That's who we kind of binding,
but that's who we're kind of letting raise our kids.
And,
and I can understand why there's very little influence of parents over
children's behavior.
I don't think that's natural.
I think that's just the way society has been structured or rather the society
we've kind of inherited.
And I really would like to see,
um,
I said this on my show all the time to people who call in.
It's like,
wow,
we're going to have kids,
but I got to work.
It's like you don't,
you know,
I mean,
you went into debt to go to school.
this is important.
Just at least for the first couple of years,
you know,
my daughter's and her brain is like 90% done now.
There are five.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's unfortunately going to be crazy.
So now you're really stuck on that train train,
right?
We
were,
we were at a hotel this weekend and uh,
we went skiing and the three year old,
uh,
zipped up her,
her luggage,
but she forgot something.
And so my wife says,
honey,
you're not going to fit that.
You have to put your boots in there and she goes,
ah,
Shit.
And there's something about seeing a three year old go ah shit.
And you only realize,
Ooh,
okay,
that is the human condition.
First of all,
that's obviously me.
Okay.
I need to either stop saying that or embrace the idea of a three year old
saying it.
It's one of those,
cause I don't think there's anything wrong with saying,
oh shit.
When you leave say,
but if you do it in certain circumstances and school and work,
it's going to be a problem.
So I have to figure out what my daughter Loves Bible stories.
Really.
I'm,
I'm an atheist.
You say once upon a time before you tell them.
Oh,
I know she knows that stories.
Okay.
Yeah,
we call him the big invisible guy.
Do you go old school,
Old Testament or do you go,
we'd do the whole thing.
Oh,
I've told her the story yet.
You know,
I'm the guy who's going to kill his son because the big invisible guy,
I say making them in an ice cream.
Like bake him in a pie with whipped cream.
Because,
you know,
it's,
that's how you say,
I don't have a knife to the throat.
I mean,
she's,
she was four,
but she loves the big visible Guy Stories.
She loves the NOAA wine.
She loves to Adam and Eve one with the snake and the apple.
It's all,
I mean,
these stories that they've,
they've stood the test of time.
There's really some of the best stories around who was going to kill his,
his son was Cain enabled know Cain and Abel where the son of Adam and eve,
they were brothers and they killed each other.
Right.
I said,
Isaac and Abraham,
I think,
I know Isaac.
And I go,
okay,
did we have a web?
Abraham?
Abraham has a son,
right?
Yeah.
So I think God,
who's asking him to kill us on forum.
Yeah.
It's a lab test.
Just because you know,
that's how,
you know,
if someone really loves you,
like,
you know,
this is why,
you give this,
um,
you give this to your,
to your wife,
you know,
like,
I would,
I would murder our offspring for you.
And that's the hallmark card that really helps your wife understand how much you
love her.
I'm just an ex boyfriend murdering our ex boyfriend.
I would find that way.
Your next boyfriend,
the beat you up.
I'll murder him.
And so,
but,
and I'm trying to tell the stories in a neutral way,
right?
Like it's,
I again,
I had my,
my opinions on all these stories and all that,
but she really likes the stories and she's a huge fan of Lucifer.
Whoa.
I mean,
Lucifer is the guy,
he is like her superhero,
you know,
like he is her mighty morphin power rangers.
She thinks he is just the coolest cause he's always standing up to big invisible
guy.
Right.
And,
um,
because she,
for her prayer is,
you know,
everyone's standing around and say,
Oh,
you have the best.
you're the best.
Oh,
you're the greatest.
I love you so much.
Oh,
you're the best.
You know.
And so,
you know,
Lucifer gets kind of tired of that and leads the rebellion and all that.
Cause,
you know,
I said,
just keep saying it.
And she said,
I'm getting tired of it.
It's like,
well,
no,
it keep saying it because it's an eternity of saying that to the gate.
Right?
And she's like,
Oh man,
I'm really tired.
I want to sit down.
It's like,
now,
you know how Lucifer,
none of it anyways,
so she's got this great,
she's just great song,
which goes basically,
Lucifer was right,
Lucifer was right.
You know,
wow.
The songs and I'm just waiting.
Cause you know,
in Canada there's some homeschooling,
which is kind of what our schooling,
what we were doing,
but a lot of them are,
are Christians,
right?
So we're going to at some point be around a bunch of Christian kids and she's
going to break into this song.
And I just,
I'm looking forward to that moment of,
I've tried to explain that,
uh,
maybe she's referring to a Beatles song.
I don't know.
I'll,
I completely bail on her at that point.
I don't know where she gets this.
Well,
the real issue is you're going to have to mingle with those Christian parents.
The real issue when you have children,
uh,
besides raising the children,
which is of course the primary one,
teaching them and everything is dealing with these other parents and seeing
it's,
it's really weird when I see people with their kids,
you know,
see how little they interact with their kids.
See How like
not appreciative they are of their kids.
How they're always distracted or
oh,
it's a ring of cell phones around the playground.
Yeah.
You know,
like throw your cell phone,
go play,
go into
stupid Mcdonald's tubes and go play with your kids.
I know a woman who's a psychologist and she picks up her kid and she's on her
phone while she's picking the kid and the kid trying to talk to her about going,
she's like,
uh Huh.
Uh Huh.
And she's texting.
It's,
you know,
I mean you just,
the kid was gone for five hours and when you picking them up,
you're texting.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
so,
it's so attractive to us though.
So easy to do.
It's so easy to ignore.
We get so used to,
you know,
the kid being around and we get so used to our own free time.
Got It.
That it's hard to drive it and she's great cause you know,
I'm trying to teach your eye contact,
right.
Because you know,
when she's a kid,
you know,
I don't know if they can't focus when they look at you,
but that tells stories like they're just watching the biggest disco light show
on the planet and you're just like some leaf or something.
Right.
And so I tried to remind her,
you know,
eye contact when we're talking,
that kind of stuff.
Right?
So the other day of course,
and I,
you know,
I try,
Oh gel,
you know,
and I,
but every now and then like I get donations,
my whole show is just donations,
right.
No ads or anything.
And so,
you know,
when a donation comes in,
it's like,
Ooh,
kibble.
You know,
like I'm,
I'm like the rat with the pellet,
you know,
that's on kibble,
what it again,
and I've got this silicon chip noise that comes in cause I'm for,
anyway.
So,
you know,
I,
the kitchen noise come in.
My daughter was telling me something really important for her and all that.
And,
and yeah,
she's great.
She's like 40 she's like,
Daddy,
I contact.
You're absolutely right.
I'm so sorry.
How rude that was of me.
I have.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's fascinating to watch their little brains develop,
isn't it?
And then watch the way they interact with each other and how they see the world
and realize that this is how a person is shaped.
And this is the number one problem that we have as a race is that we don't
respect this process and that we also don't respect this process in strangers,
especially people that we know are fucked.
People in bad neighborhoods,
people in bad circumstances,
people in a abusive families.
We know they're fucked and we don't,
we don't do anything to stop it.
One thing that I keep harping on is that if we have a resource,
whether it's a oil or gold being,
we protect that resource and,
and you know we,
we set up laws and we attach a value to it,
but our number one resource for sure is human beings.
We have created all that you see,
whether it's laptops or buildings or cars,
that's all from a human being.
The best way to ensure that that continues to go on is to have less losers in
the world.
The best way to have less losers is help out kids,
educate kids,
get on the ball with them very early and do something as a society to protect
them primary before we go into wars,
before we go into all this stupid shit that we do to spying on people's fucking
emails and looking into their cell phone record.
Before you do any of that,
how about you protect kids first?
That should be of primary importance and it should be like one of those things
where your kid,
you know,
wants to go out and play.
Like do have you done your homework?
You haven't done your homework,
you can't play.
It's that fucking simple.
You can't have your wars unless you fix the kids.
Okay.
And they're there.
So
smart.
And I,
you know,
I was the human,
I've had a whole bunch of experts,
a on my show,
a which is,
you talk about the native intelligence of,
of kids.
Like kids can start doing mathematical reasoning at seven or eight months of
age.
They can start,
do using empathy at 14 months.
And my daughter at the age of four,
we started playing a game called subjective versus objective.
You know,
like is this something subjective?
Like I like ice cream or is this something objective like ice cream is made from
milk and you know,
we'd pointed staff and say subject or objective,
you know,
I like jazz,
it's subjective or objective.
And she's like,
Bang,
rattling them off.
The other day she was saying to me,
Oh dad,
you know,
we've talked a lot.
She's always asking me about the show.
In fact,
I should have been taking notes because she's asked me all about you,
uh,
what's going to be the topic?
And I said,
you know what,
I have no idea.
I know it's gonna be interesting to chat with Joe,
no idea what we're going to talk about and was best.
Yeah,
yeah.
She's asked all about,
you know,
where you're from and what you do and she's awesome.
Native by mixed martial arts and all that kind of stuff.
And uh,
um,
and so she's gonna ask me all the time and I do some shows on economics and so
we talked a little bit about that,
you know,
fee money and all that.
And I diagram stuff out for her and she gets it really,
we've gone through the whole history of the Second World War the other day.
She says,
you know,
my Daddy,
I think I've decided what I want to do.
I think when I get bigger,
I think I just like to work.
I think I want to be the government.
I'd love to be the government because I just,
I want to type whatever I wanted to my bank account.
And I was just like,
wow,
you just nailed the Federal Reserve right there in a night.
Whatever I want into my bank account.
Vango via your old logic,
but perfect.
It is what it is.
They can print their own money.
Yeah.
It's beautiful.
Great system.
Yeah.
No.
When I come out of the sort of libertarian world,
right,
so I mean I'm an anarchist,
but I come out of the libertarian world and Libertarians very much as we talked
about La nonaggression principle and so on,
and I've been fighting this,
this battle in the libertarian world and in other worlds as well around,
you know,
things is to me is basic a spanking,
right?
I wasn't sure,
I mean we touched on this,
just throw a few stats for the audience who hasn't seen it before.
More than 90% of parents of toddlers stayed.
They spank their child.
Toddlers,
60 61% of moms,
three to five year olds have spank their child.
In the past week,
boys spanked a lot more than girls.
Boys are also diagnosed with Adhd,
which is one of the symptoms of spanking a lot more than girls spanking.
Can continue into the adolescent years,
30 to 40% of people in junior high,
kids in junior high.
I still being spanked.
Moms do spank children a lot more than fathers do.
Even controlling for time spent with kids and all of that kind of stuff.
Uh,
economic status doesn't have a huge amount to do with spanking,
but cultural dat.
So African Americans,
uh,
do a,
do a lot more corporate punishment.
Uh,
religious conservative,
fundamentalist,
do a lot more corporal punishment and so on.
And this to me is,
it's such a fundamental thing.
I'm,
I'm very much for philosophy that you can do philosophy that you can act on
values that you can do is,
I don't like the Federal Reserve.
I think central banking is a monstrous cancer in the eyeball of society,
but I can't really do much about it other than rant and rave about it.
But we can't,
what we can do is,
you know,
do some basics,
like stop hitting kids.
You know,
that to me is a very fundamental thing.
And in the libertarian community,
that's a challenge.
Lard,
a lot of um,
a religious conservatives in the libertarian community as you know,
like on the underwriter,
wrong republicans.
There tend to be more religious people on the left,
a secularist less religious people but more socialists and so on.
And it is really tough,
you know,
to just get that basic thing across.
We tell kids not to hit each other and we hit kids and we've all,
I dunno if you,
you,
they,
you see bad parenting sometimes when you're out and you act,
you actually,
and I'll usually say something to the parents because I don't want my,
my,
I think it's the right thing to do.
I don't want my daughter to see me be all about the ethics and then not talk to
people doing something wrong.
But you can see parents hit kids saying don't hit your sister.
And that the fact that they can do that without their heads exploding from this
wormhole contradiction of Pretzel logic is just astounding.
But it is something,
we still have a long way to go in.
I think we're kind of slowly getting there,
but we have a long way to go in just let's not hit kids.
Yeah.
I think how much of the world would change if we didn't do that?
I think we would be virtually unrecognizable as a culture.
I couldn't agree more.
You know,
I read this article recently on my message board.
Uh,
I don't have it in front of me,
so I apologize to whoever posted it,
but it was about a man who got stuck in the financial system of divorce and it
was from his perspective,
he committed suicide,
lit himself on fire.
I started reading his perspective and they came to his house and he had his
initial issue because he slapped his daughter in the mouse so hard that her
mouth was bleeding and he did it because she was licking his hands.
She kept licking his hands.
So he slapped her in the mouth til her mouth has been.
And then everything I,
I stopped reading right there.
I'm like,
I don't want to know this guy.
I don't,
I,
I'm sad that he was so fucked up that he committed suicide.
But if I saw a guy slap his daughter in the face because she was,
you know,
was licking his hand,
I would have to really suppress my urge to strangle him.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's violence.
That's violence to someone who cannot defend themselves and can't leave.
Not only that,
to be there,
not only that,
it's,
it's fundamentally the most fucked up kind of violence because you're doing it
to a developing human being who you allegedly love.
You're teaching them to violence is a part of life by the people that they
respect the most and that it can be done to you at any time when you don't agree
with whatever fucking guidelines and rules they've set up,
like licking your hand.
And my daughter was licking my hand.
I'd be laughing my ass off.
I would think.
It's so funny I do that.
I'd smack her in the mouth.
It's just fucking insane.
But people,
they fall into this pattern and they don't,
don't,
don't realize that violence is violence.
Just because you're not going to hurt the kid that bad.
You're just going to spank them and you think it's no big deal.
Fuck.
Yeah,
it's a big deal because that kid,
it's a horrific situation.
You're doing something in,
they can't control.
You're holding their arm,
they're moving their body and then this big hand comes in slaps their ass and
they feel pain and they feel confused cause you've acted out against them.
You've not only acted out against them,
you've done it yelling at slapping and it's a terrible,
it's terrible precedent to set a terrible idea to plant in a child's mind.
And it's unnecessary.
It's just not necessary for you to tell me that you can't sit down and reason
with your child and,
and do it with love.
And the,
yeah,
they're going to freak out and fucking flail sometimes get mad and yell.
And that's because they're a fucking child.
You piece of shit.
You don't smack them.
You know,
you just
hitting your friends.
It's like hitting your for don't be,
don't hit anybody man.
Well and,
and in particular,
you know,
the moral concentration of like black hearted nastiness,
you hit your wife,
she,
she got to date you.
She got to,
you know,
you had an engagement.
She,
you know,
she,
she chose you and you chose her.
But if you hit your wife,
she at least had to,
did you get to test drive you?
She,
you know,
and then she can leave at anytime.
She's an adult,
she's got shelters,
she's got whatever.
People will help her,
hopefully.
But kids,
they didn't choose you as parents,
you know,
and they can't leave and they have no options.
And I say this to my daughter,
you know,
I say,
um,
I know you're not here by choice.
You know,
you didn't choose me as a dad.
I choose to have kids.
And you didn't choose me as a dad.
The way I have to parent is I want to parent.
Like if my daughter didn't have a choice of any doubt in the world that she
would choose me like,
and so I imagine these all day long.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and what about feedback?
You know,
I go to my local pizza joint half the time I have to fill out,
they give me this comment card to fill out,
you know,
how did you like the pizza?
You know what's good for you?
Was it bad for you?
You know,
they wanna know they wanna have a good pizza and how many times the parents do
that with their kids say,
how am I doing?
You know,
how's your experience of my parenting?
what's more important slice of pizza or your relationship with your offspring.
You know,
ask them how you're doing.
How could they have been better?
What did I do that that you liked?
What did I do that you didn't like?
And all that.
Get that kind of feedback.
I don't know.
It's just weird that we don't even think of doing that.
Well,
I think your perspective is very unique in the fact that you are a stay at home
dad and you do have the resources to be able to do that.
It's,
it's,
it's really hard for a lot of people.
And that's while you were talking about before,
that number's pretty crazy.
The 20 minutes a week.
I didn't know that it was that low,
but honestly,
not shocked.
I don't have a regular life,
but I've dabbled in regular life.
You know,
I've had like jobs that take me away for a long period of time during the day.
And I could only imagine what kind of energy you have to devote to a kid.
If the mother,
both the mother and the father both leave the house all day long,
work an eight hour day,
and then come home.
How much is left?
There's not even much time.
The is going to be awake.
Yeah.
How much energy do you have left?
How much focus or you're putting on that kid during the day?
And,
and we have this again,
a couple more stats.
Um,
we have this idea that the moms have to be there and the dads can be there.
But a study conducted by Dr. Kyle Pruitt found that infants between seven and 30
months respond more favorably to being picked up by their fathers.
He also found a father's parenting style is beneficial for a child's physical,
cognitive,
and emotional and behavioral development and tend to reassure toddlers when they
become frustrated while fathers encouraged them to manage their frustration.
And my daughter's like this.
So she's learning to do all these things and,
and most of her friends are older cause you know,
we're nothing like youngest parents on the block.
And so a lot of her friends can do stuff better than she can.
She gets frustrated and me helping her talk you through that frustration and
reminding her that I didn't know how to do this stuff and you know,
she's trying to do racket sports and I remember took me years to become good at
racket sports.
So,
uh,
so that's important for,
for kids as well.
I mean,
it's really important to remember,
you know,
the mom and the kid,
they used to be the same freaking person.
You know,
like she grew her,
they were like,
it's like my arm,
you know,
it's not like a separate thing.
Whereas they had to have a little bit more objectivity around that.
A longer term study that this guy did to prove that the father's active
involvement with his kids from birth to adolescence promotes greater emotional
balance,
stronger curiosity,
a stronger sense of self assurance,
additional studies during the first five years of a child's life.
The father's role is more influential than the mothers in how the child learns
to manage his or her body,
navigate social,
social,
social circumstances in play.
And the last one is,
this is in 1996 study that I was referring to before by McGill university at the
single most important childhood factor in developing empathy is paternal
involvement in childcare.
The study further concluded that children who spend time alone binding with
their children more than twice per week,
brought up the most compassionate adults.
Um,
so how do they measure that?
How's that quantifiable?
Um,
it seems like a weird,
all those statistics seem very odd.
It's like how do you know what caused a person to have more empathy?
How do you know what caused a person to be able to move better?
And I mean,
how do you,
how do you work?
Well what they prove that again it's sort of a many to many relationships.
So they ask the father is you know,
how often were you involved?
And maybe they even measured them if it's sort of a live study and then they
measured the compassion and then they measure a whole bunch of other things.
And if the other things don't change the compassion measure,
but then the parental involvement is what moves the needle,
then they assume that that's close to causal.
But isn't the issue also the parental involvement?
Like say if a father is involved a lot in the kid's life,
he's also probably likely involved in the relationship with the wife and maybe
their wife bid would be more happy.
The father and the wife would be more happy and because of that they would both
be better parents.
So it could,
it might not just be that the impact of having a man around does all these
things and creates an empathy.
It might be the impact of having a successful family as well.
Right.
Right now.
And that certainly is true.
And again,
I didn't run the studies.
I assume that they've tried,
like whenever you questioned,
that's all we tried to tease it out this way or that way and they,
they to try to find that answer.
Um,
but I do think that compassion
again,
you know,
I mean your marriage,
you've got,
you've got kids floating around and all that and I'm floating,
but
they were floating at one point and then they came out through the magic
chamber.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think,
you know,
I mean my wife's skills as a parent are fantastic and,
um,
but,
but there are some differences between us,
you know,
and I don't know whether it's biological or whether it's just the way we were
raised or whatever,
but,
uh,
you know,
I encourage more risk taking a,
I'm,
I encourage,
you know,
if you fall off,
horse get back up and again,
kind of stuff.
And I think that's just on a kind of a natural kind of difference.
And,
um,
I'm also more encouraging of,
you know,
my daughter is like crazy friendly.
I keep thinking she's going to go up to someone,
sometimes an unfriendly world,
like a cheese up to a greater,
you know,
and just kind gets shredded cause you know,
we go places and she just goes up to kids and says hi,
would you like to be friends?
And that's cool.
Fantastic.
The people up a little,
you know,
oh I love it.
Everybody was on ecstasy.
That's how we would interact with each other.
And that was one of the things that we got it a little bit off topic,
but one of the things that I wanted to complete this,
this thought on when you were talking about antidepressants and um,
we were talking about the good and the bad of them.
I think right now one of the issues that we have with this idea of manipulating
human neurochemistry is that it's not really done.
There's,
it's not a complete art form yet.
It's not something like dying your hair.
If your hair is gray and you want to have black hair or you simply go to the
market and you buy some hair color and you put it in your hair and now your
hair's black,
it really is that fucking easy.
I mean,
they've got it down to a science.
You can see guys that are fucking 80 years old,
they have jet black hair and it looks ridiculous.
The Reagan.
Yeah,
but I think we,
we do have the potential,
just like we have mastered virtually every other aspect of our world that we
live in,
whether it's high speed communication or the ability to,
you know,
combustion engines with him ion batteries.
One day they're going to figure out how to engineer consciousness and you have
this,
you have this opportunity to take a pill or get a shot or whatever and you have
ultimate clarity and you fucking think much better and you're a better person.
I keep swinging my hands for the air and knocking shit on my keyboard.
I am literally retarded when it comes to that.
I'm looking for something to hand you,
right?
I got some paper towels here.
It didn't,
didn't really get on anything and just get a little bit on my screen,
but I think that one day they're going to have the ability to do what we would
like them to be able to do,
to figure out how to engineer human consciousness ideally to make in a pill form
or in,
you know,
I mean in a shot or in some sort of genetic manipulation.
I think that is that possible and is that bad?
Is that going to take away from being a human being?
If we're,
I think that would be a great tragedy.
Why is that?
If we made it awesome in pill form,
life would be fucking literally everything we'd been searching for.
No struggle.
Just talking to that.
That's like everyone being born with $1 billion is just talking about no
resistant is it sounds that we know that to a large degree,
I think.
I think that we know that to a large degree with our current state of
consciousness.
But what I'm saying is if we engineered it past this ape monkey paradigm that we
live in right now,
and boom,
with one shot,
they give you this Buddha thing,
it's called the Buddhists.
Would you take it?
I don't.
I might probably you would.
I don't know if everybody else was taking it.
You're a natural father.
I'm a father.
I think I would,
uh,
consider it.
I would want to know what the,
would you want your kids to take it?
Um,
I would want to know what the results were.
Look if the entire world took it and then we would engineer consciousness past
this stage where we are now and completely restructure society that have no
evil,
no problems.
We think that we have to have a Yang to have a yen.
And in our current state we do.
But is that the ultimate end all?
Are we not continually evolving?
Is this life that we live now not much easier and safer than it was living in a
time of gangs con?
Well,
it certainly is.
Well isn't,
it isn't arguable that a thousand years from now it would,
it would adapt and change and become something different than it is now.
We have the technology and exponentially as that technology.
None of your audience,
no.
$6 million man references.
Do they play?
A few of them do right?
Barely alive.
That's right.
Gentlemen.
We can rebuild him.
We have the technology.
I met him recently.
Very nice guy.
Wow.
I think,
I think he's a pretty fun guy.
But anyway,
it's pretty cool to meet him I imagine.
Yeah.
The cool shows.
His handshake.
It's very firms.
I man,
I imagined it would be Steve Austin,
um,
Lee majors.
Great Guy.
I am I a fan.
I think we do have that.
I think we have that,
that tech.
Okay.
So let me,
let me ask you a think.
We have it now.
We engineer consciousness.
Yeah.
I mean neuroplasticity and,
and focusing on what I would argue is it's the old Eris routinely and idea that
we look for something come you Domenico a or,
or,
or happiness and happiness is according to Aristotle.
Happiness is the one thing we seek for its own sake,
right?
Like we don't,
we get on a bus to go somewhere,
right.
We take a cab to get home and once we're home we've arrived there and we don't
stay on the bus,
will stay on the cap and most things we do in life are there to,
to pursue happiness.
Right.
Like I came here because it's sunny.
No,
I came here for you.
I came here and the son and the son and the son both makes it very easy.
I really enjoyed our last conversation and I think it was great to,
to get the messages out that I think are really important for people.
And so I came down here because it will make me happy so far.
You and the coffee have made me very happy.
I'm not saying necessarily in that order,
but they're both in the mix.
Caveman coffee works.
It really is good stuff.
I'll tell you that.
Um,
I knew that you were going to butter me up.
Yeah.
That's how I do it.
I butter people up,
but literally,
and so yeah,
Aristotle said,
so how do you achieve happiness?
Well,
acts happened as he said,
it's the pursuit of excellence,
particularly in virtue.
And now virtue for Aristotle was a little funky because he was pro slavery.
So yeah,
it's,
it's been,
you know,
they didn't have labor saving devices other than other human beings.
So,
so I think that we do have the capacity to be quite happy and,
and to,
to achieve a state of not contentment because I think contentment is for like
cows and,
and uh,
stuff that they excrete.
But I think to,
to,
to achieve happiness,
we pursue virtue,
which is,
you know,
we,
we act to do good.
We fight the bad guys.
We try and reform the people on the fence.
We try and encourage those in pursuit of virtue.
And I mean,
let me ask you this question.
How is your conscience,
right?
You know,
this thing that you accumulate,
this sort of unconscious thing that accumulates the good and bad that you've
done in your life.
My conscience is pretty easy.
I think I've done some things wrong.
I think I've done a lot of things right.
My conscience is pretty easy.
How your conscience do you think in the sort of the sum total,
you know that thing you go in of Saint Peter at the end
of your life and he tallies up you sort of the good and bad.
How's your conscience as far as that goes?
Well in your life generally I engage in not so frequent but quite strong
psychedelic activities.
And in doing so roller coasters with your eyes closed is that,
well the most common one for me is a sensory deprivation tank.
Do that all the time.
So you face yourself in that environment without distractions,
right?
Yes,
you certainly do.
And that's one of the more challenging aspects of it and one of the things that
people are most afraid of because of that.
And um,
I certainly have done things wrong.
I certainly have made mistakes and I certainly think that those mistakes have
given me more empathy,
more understanding,
more objectivity in the analysis of those mistakes have made me a better person.
And the subsequent reaction to my analysis of those mistakes and made me a
better person.
You change,
you evaluate and change and all that.
So you know,
when you say your conscious,
is your conscience clean?
No,
no.
It's fucking littered with bodies.
But the result of that,
that life has made me a far better bodies,
not zombies.
Right?
Yeah.
A woman who I am right now.
Yes.
My conscience is clear the way I treat people now.
Yeah.
On hundred percent.
I'm very,
I try to be very nice.
I tried to be right before.
I think you do a lot of good in the world.
You bring a lot of,
I think good thinkers to people's attention.
Hopefully myself included.
I think that through your comedies we talked about before,
I think you give people a very empathetic relationship to their own physicality
and,
and uh,
bring sort of some of the secret stuff in people's lives into the open and have
them have good humor about it so much.
I think you do a lot of good and I think that's what you say,
that you quite happy.
Well,
yeah.
And I'm very happy.
But I,
and I think that that good though is a very reciprocal,
it's,
it's a very even relationship between audience and me.
I think I easily get as much out of this podcast is that people who listened to
it too.
And I think that's one of the reasons why it's so harmonious and one of the
reasons why it's so easy to do.
And also one of the reasons why the relationship that I have with the audience
when I meet them,
it's like I think they know that I'm as happy about all of this as they are and
the people that it's benefited their lives and they've been exposed to all these
different people like yourself and other interesting people that have had on the
show.
I have also been exposed to those people.
It's been exposed to you,
been exposed to whether it's Sam Harris or uh,
uh,
you know,
Goswami,
the theoretical physicists are all these different fascinating people that I've
had on the podcast.
Graham Hancock.
Glad Nauseum,
Joey is all these people have made my life a more fascinating life for sure.
So it's been a completely mutual,
beneficial situation.
So when you say like you've done a lot of good,
well,
it's done a lot of good for me.
So I really think it's a very old,
yeah,
it's a completely even exchange.
What I've found is a path that I find to be a both fascinating and enjoyable,
and I've gone down that path.
I've been very fortunate to find it and then pursue it.
That's unusual,
you know,
for your profession,
right?
I mean it was,
what is my comedians who do a or public figures and so on,
who bring intellectuals to
a mainstream audience?
I mean,
well that's because I've kind of resisted the idea of being pigeonholed into one
sort of occupation.
Right?
I mean,
what I do is just,
I'm a person and there's a bunch of things that I enjoy.
Right.
You know,
one of the things that I enjoy is hunting.
This thing that I've really become fascinated with lately.
That's for a lot of people's repulsive.
I've had,
you know,
incredible insults.
I mean,
whether they think they come from,
well not only that there's the,
the the do no do the least harm principle.
It's really kind of fucked.
But the reality of farming is that unless you're organically farming and your
own garden,
you're actually killing more animals per pound of you know,
of grain and for pound of rice then you do per pound of beef.
It's really kind of fucked.
There's,
there's some study on it like how many animals get ground up and those machines
that they use to churn up crops and Oh,
is that right?
How much displacement they do to the,
into the natural habitat of certain animals.
When you plant crops and there's a,
you know this,
it's very,
it's,
it's ideal if you can grow your own stuff.
If you can grow your own stuff and you want to be like a Vegan,
you want to have like the smallest footprint possible.
That's the way to do it.
Grow your own stuff and you know,
and,
and make sure that you don't harm anything and the,
the cultivation of your fruits and vegetables.
But if you don't,
boy,
you're still participating with you,
believe it or not,
you're participating,
you're participating in slaughter.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I,
I have some sympathy and again,
you know,
if you can do less harm,
I think that's great.
And after high school,
I wanted somebody for school.
I ended up going up to work,
uh,
in,
in northern Ontario,
like past the tree line where you had to fly in to do claim staking and gold
panning and all that kind of stuff.
And you know,
when you really in Mother Nature,
and this was like,
you know,
minus 50 degree weather in a tent for months.
I mean,
when you really in Mother Nature,
you realize she's,
she's kind of a bitch.
She doesn't give a fuck about you.
Like she'll just,
you know,
fucking tree will fall on your head.
And that's it for you.
I mean,
you know,
it's really,
uh,
you know,
one time we got snowed in,
like we couldn't get the plane in with supplies and you realize,
look,
you're looking at a box of food and you're like,
you know,
when we're out of this,
it's getting all kinds of like stuck on a mountain looking at people.
I actually was thinking,
you know,
you see those,
um,
these are looney tunes cartoons.
So again,
for your younger audience members,
please ask your parents.
You know,
like when some guys really hungry and he looks across at some other guy and he
turns into like this steaming chicken wing or something like that.
Today though you couldn't.
But I was looking at,
there was one guy who was kind of plumping the in the camp and you know,
he actually just started to look well marbled to me.
Like I didn't think of it as fat anymore.
I thought of it as nutritious.
When things get ugly,
people do tend to start leaning towards survive.
Yes.
And a lot of times like we,
we like nature because we are a comfortable distance from it.
You know,
like we've got our air conditioning,
we got our antibiotics,
we've got,
you know,
the people in the Middle Ages,
they were really close to nature and we died like flies,
you know,
like childbirth was half fatal to like half the women have,
every fucking story has a big bad wolf in it.
And the reason being is at wolves,
we're fucking killing people on a regular base.
Yeah.
Until people figured out firearms wolves were killing people like crazy.
It was a really common thing for people to get killed by wolves.
You know,
one,
one stupid ass flea comes across a in a rat from the Middle East and suddenly a
third of Europe is dying from the black death.
I mean,
I in nature is great to visit,
but it's not a fucking Ansell Adams poster.
I mean,
she is a sociopathic bitch who will wipe you out as soon as look at you.
There's a story from 1450 that I've told them the podcast once before,
but for the,
this in this line of thinking,
there was a,
uh,
a series of murders in Paris in 1450 by wolves were murderers.
I guess it's just PR predatory.
They killed 40 people.
Wolves killed 40 fucking people in Paris and 1450.
And we are no different to them than a Caribou or anything else that they can
eat.
It's just when we have protected ourselves completely with cities and cars and
guns and all these things,
then it doesn't become an issue.
And then we look at them and like,
oh,
beautiful nature.
But that beautiful nature gives zero fucks about you and we'll absolutely eat
your baby in front of you.
Oh yeah.
They have no problem with it.
Whether it's a fox in London,
they actually have had issues recently where foxes have broken into children's
bedrooms and attack the children while they're asleep.
Rats.
If babies in Harlem,
I mean rats will just eat the baby's face.
Oh,
they just monstrous.
It's,
it's,
it's so heartless and the,
it's all about survival.
And we've a radically did that by,
I love it and I love it too big at the top of the food chain.
I'm sorry that that we had to kill a whole bunch of stuff to get here,
but at the beginning it was us or them,
you know,
like I'm glad that some comment came and took the heads off the dinosaurs
because otherwise we'd just be little rodents that they're eating.
Like I'm sorry that a whole bunch of,
we were on top of a big pile of bodies,
but I'd rather be on top of then in them.
I have no problem with killing dinosaurs.
I have no problem with the media that killed their,
the asteroid that killed the dinosaurs.
I'm happy that it happened.
It's like the big mammalian airstrike from outer space.
You know,
let's make some room in the food chain.
We've got to grow people.
We got a podcast to do in 4 billion years.
I used to have this bit about this people that I talked to once that we're
working to save the Komodo Dragon,
they were going to the Komodo islands in two weeks.
Let's work.
Make sure the Komodo dragon populations are good and healthy.
I'm like,
what?
Why would you want those heartless fucking monsters?
Get a few of them.
Stick them in a zoo.
Shoot the rest of them in the head.
Are you fucking evil?
These are evil reptiles.
Others so evil.
Tell me,
tell me why.
I got horrible monster.
I don't know much about biggest lizards on the planet and they water buffalo
people.
Anything on that island buffaloes.
Oh fuck yeah,
they do.
They eat them by biting them.
They're huge.
They're enormous.
You never seen a Komodo Dragon.
I mean,
Jamie pope a photo of a Komodo dragons mouth.
They used to think that they carry botulism their saliva that used to be
thought,
but now they realize that what happens is the environment that dragons live in,
it's so hot and tropical and that a lot of times they're biting into water
buffalo and all these different things that are exposed to moisture,
and it's just a septic nature of their environment because water buffaloes piss
and shit in the water that they live in.
And then when this Komodo dragon bites them,
he opens up their flesh and the blood gets exposed to all the toxins and the
teeth waiting for whatever the next bite.
So it's venomous.
They're just like disgust,
disgust,
look at it,
look at that image.
Evil Saliva.
One of them though a bit,
Sharon stone's husband on the foot,
this dump,
fuck,
he got into a cage with a Komodo dragon and he had white socks on and the thing
thought his foot was a rabbit.
It's a clamped down on his foot and would let go.
And he almost lost his foot there.
It's really,
they're really fucking gangster poplar.
He got into a Komodo Dragon.
Oh,
it's so cute.
I would do it if I was in a tank,
again,
a cage with it and I had a Samurai sword fuck outta here.
Those things are horrifying.
But these people that I met were like really dedicating all of their time and
effort.
And I'm like,
that is fascinating.
But those fucking lizards don't give a shit about you buddy.
And now I can understand it.
That's some big ecosystem thing.
Yes.
But they got rid of the predators a in Australia I think it was.
And then the,
basically the rabbit's just ate the entire continent.
So I can like,
if there's some balance in nature of thing,
you know,
I think that's fine.
But,
uh,
I am very,
very glad to,
uh,
to not be around wild animals.
You know,
like when I was working up north,
we had to be armed because I mean,
there are bears who might not have had a meal in like a month and they don't
care.
They'll just,
they'll just come and rip your face off and eat it.
And that's,
you know,
wolves and all that.
We really had to be careful out there.
And this,
uh,
yeah.
So all the people who were like nature is basically cuddle.
It's like,
that's great.
That's cause you go hiking in Yellowstone aren't on clearly marked parts when
people have cleared all the predators away.
And you know,
not even Yellowstone,
you'll 70,
maybe because they have black bears.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I,
Alex Honnold,
you know,
he has,
he's the climber.
Uh,
he's one of the world's best.
He's on 60 minutes.
That one.
Yeah.
And he was on the podcast.
I've got Yellowstone confused with Yosemite and we were talking about bear desk.
I'm like,
man,
bears and fucking died in,
in Yosemite.
Right.
And he was like,
no,
I don't know.
Bears or die.
And I was,
I got,
I didn't know that.
There's two different I had in my head,
Yellowstone and Yosemite became the same thing,
right.
Because two people over the last couple of years were killed in Yellowstone by
grizzlies and just fucking hikers.
Just people wandering around and you run into a bear in the wrong situation.
And that is a giant 1800 pound monster or 1200 pounds or 800 pound,
whatever the fuck it is.
There are bears there are enormous.
It's think of a giant dog,
an 800 pound dog that wants to eat you.
Like it's going to eat you your fuck can't get away.
You can't get,
they can put you on the fast,
they can climb up and you cannot get away from those guys.
And I run up trees,
we run straight up a tree and black bears especially
can run up a tree like a,
like a cat.
Yeah.
Oh.
And,
and I remember being in a,
in a tent again in the middle of nowhere.
Um,
I was with this tiny Japanese woman who was like incredibly strong.
She was literally like made of muscle.
It was astounding.
Anyway,
but,
and we were in this tent and I heard this,
oh wow.
You know,
snuffling around and,
and you know,
we did all that.
We hung the,
the,
the food and the trees and all that.
You don't never want any food around,
obviously when you're sleeping and then this kind of stuff.
And,
I mean,
you literally think this is like,
this is my last 20 seconds in this planet.
You know,
this,
this is it.
You know this thing.
Cause you know,
even if your arms,
uh,
there's only so much you can do.
Well you have to get off a shot very quickly and you have to hope that it's
scares the bear away because if you just shoot them,
unless you have a really high powered rifle,
like a pistol shot 38.
Yeah,
a shotgun is not good enough.
Now I'm not going to kill him.
But what it will do is it will annoy him to the point where he killed you
quicker.
So that won't be a lot of suffering.
So you know,
you won't,
you know,
it'll rip your own head off and you won't get to see your own better off putting
the gun your mouth simply.
Yeah,
that might be the mood.
But the problem is then,
you know,
they kind of identify you but dental records,
cause you're,
you know,
your teeth is sprayed out all over the forest.
But so stuff like that gives you a pretty healthy appreciation for the bears
killed dogs near the camp and stuff like,
I mean,
it's,
it's seriously dangerous stuff out there and I'm very happy to,
to live in a civilized area where I can go visit.
Nature and nature is absolutely beautiful when it is not trying to kill you.
Uh,
it's like the,
you know,
the ocean is beautiful.
I love scuba diving and snorkeling.
That's a flying over the coral,
but the fee,
as long as nothing's taken your leg off,
it's a beautiful,
beautiful experience.
But that taking the leg off thing is a pretty important part of the equation.
And the people forget it.
Who spent a lot of time in cities.
Yeah.
People do forget it.
That taking your leg off as a real thing to think about when you go swimming
anywhere in the world where there's sharks,
you know,
you might think that it's not going to happen to you because it hasn't happened
to that guy or that guy,
or this person has a surfboard over there.
Look,
this person's snorkeling.
I'm fine.
No,
you're not.
You're rolling the dice.
You're getting,
it's like if you go into the woods,
the idea of like that,
that somehow or another,
these millions of sharks going to avoid you.
Like likely yes,
because there's so much real estate,
but it's like if we've,
we've,
we knew that Werewolf's were real,
but there was only one of them and it was out in the woods.
How often would you go in the woods when it was a full moon?
You would never fucking go in the woods because you'd go,
fuck it.
What if I picked the wrong night in the wrong place and I get out there and the
wolf man has right there.
He eats me.
Well,
the fucking sharks are sharks all day,
24 hours a day,
seven days a week,
365 days a year.
The wolf man is only the wolf man once a month.
And you know,
but we,
you know,
that we not that terrified of nature because all the kids toys are like cute
predators.
Like if you go down to the woods tonight,
you're in for a big surprise,
you know,
cause the teddy bears or having a picnic.
But the real end of that story is Bra.
I know.
Isn't it funny
that teddy bear is like a con?
That's that.
That is so common.
It's a completely comments 20 it's only common now.
I don't think they had bear toys when bears could kill you.
You know,
now that there's no bears around,
they can be cute and cuddly and you can have the lion king and all of that
because nobody's around lions.
But you know,
in Africa,
people still get regularly eaten by lions.
I bet you there are not a lot of lion toys lying around that are cute and
cuddly.
I bet you're right.
And if you think about some of the animals that we have a,
what's the term anthropomorphism?
Is that it?
When you take a person or project human characteristics onto a nonhuman like
Tony,
the tiger there,
like Tony looking at your children,
he's a fucking asshole.
Great to eat.
Why are you making him cute?
They're tired because we don't have any tigers around there in zoos.
And you take pictures and so fun fact about India.
There's a place called the cinder bands were tires have killed 300,000 people
over the last 200 years.
300,000 people have been killed by tigers in the Sunderbans.
It's so incredible.
I had a bit about it.
I'm one of my past comedy specials cause it was just,
it's such a ridiculous statistic.
One tiger killed three men in a boat of five swim out to the boat,
killed a man,
dragged him back to the water,
to the beach,
jumped back in the water,
killed another guy,
hop and did it three times before.
Either got bored or they got away for full.
Yeah.
I mean they,
they swim incredibly fast and they're really aggressive.
They've got these teeth that can tell by your Jackie is yes,
they're sensitive.
Yeah.
I mean the beat,
that's his job stuff.
Yeah.
They adjust.
Well that's where they're designed for,
you know,
I mean they are literally designed to clean up anything slow.
They're there as population control.
That's what they're there for.
And also making sure the hood stays strong.
You know,
getting rid of the slowest and the city gets then the oldest and keep this heard
strong
to think of it that way.
But again,
this is the Yin and the Yang.
If you gave the tiger's a pill and make everything groovy and there's no more
need to hunt,
what would we have?
Well,
we have nature but the,
but the real question is if,
if we are going to engineer that,
but what are,
what are we going to do with the natural world?
What are we going to do with the bears and the Tigers and the crocodiles?
Well,
I mean of course the natural human predators.
Yeah,
that's this weird idea.
And I think it comes out of religion that,
I mean there's a couple of things that are problematic which come out of
religion and some of them are obviously kind of obvious,
but some of them I think are more subtle.
Like the issue of the soul to me is always really interesting.
Like this,
this in the religious idea,
and not all religions,
but a lot of religions,
you know,
you have this eternal part of you called the soul,
which is uncorruptible,
uh,
which can all,
and so,
you know,
when they say,
you know that he's a bad guy,
but if you really can,
if you reach through,
if you connect with him,
there's,
you know,
there's good in some way or and all that kind of stuff.
I think that's a really dangerous idea and it's scientifically seems to be
entirely false.
You know,
like people who are sociopaths don't get better.
They don't reform.
They will become canning and they,
but they've tried everything.
They've tried injecting sociopath with LSD and say,
shit,
well bullets or the cure and there are not pretty common like one in 25 people.
It's,
yeah,
I certainly come across them too.
And these are the human predators and I mean,
it's fairly easy to create them.
If you really traumatize a whole lot of kids,
then you can,
like they,
a lot of them came out of her chest cues,
um,
Romania because he banned abortion.
And a lot of women who would otherwise have had abortions put these kids into
these orphanages where they were fed and taken care of but nobody ever touched
them.
And then I think it was in France,
that was when this came out,
a whole bunch of French families adopted these a Romanian orphanages kids and
they were strangling their cats and they would throw in there other kids out of
windows and stuff and they would just,
and they come unfixable completely unfixable from the jump.
I mean like how old were they when they adopted them?
Usually it's within,
if you do this a,
if it's after two or three years,
it's usually a reversible,
cause you know,
the brain development,
the development of empathy is like three years in or psychopaths empathy,
is it 10 to 12 different brain centers all have to fire in harmony.
And you also have to develop these things called mirror neurons,
which are I think completely fascinated the biological basis of empathy island.
Completely Geeky.
Fascinating to me.
But,
uh,
since empathy I think is the most important resource in the world,
if you have that,
all other resource will be taken care of.
But Mirror neurons are,
if you see someone taking nuts shot,
you go,
oh,
you know,
like you kind of get it in your body are those are mirror neurons and you can,
you can make them or deny them in monkeys very easily,
right?
I mean,
if you just give them all the food and drink that they need,
uh,
but you just give them like a,
a simulated mom,
like the doesn't actually interact with them and you isolate them and you don't
even have to traumatize them.
You don't have to hit them.
You don't have to scare them if you do that,
they gave even worse.
But then they grow up with,
with no particular empathy because they don't get that sort of back and forth.
I mean,
babies are born with it.
One freaky thing that babies can do is write out of the womb like right when
they're born.
If you stick your tongue out at a baby,
it will stick its tongue out back at you,
which is a completely freaky thing to do when you think about it.
They've never seen a town and they don't know that you have the same,
but they,
so if you develop mirror neurons then you won't get sociopathy because you will
have empathy.
Right?
And people who spank fundamentally are acting against empathy and they're
teaching their children to act against empathy because you're doing exactly what
your child desperately does not want you to do.
And so you're really screwing with with empathy and so on.
And so the development of the non development of mirror neurons appears to be
something that cannot be corrected later in life.
It's just this,
it's like if you don't get exposed to language between like two and five,
you just never really learn it.
And there's this crazy,
and this is why when I talk about fixing the world or having a paradise on
earth,
which relative to what we have now,
I think we can have,
it's a multigenerational process because if the kids are screwed up that early,
it appears to be irreversible and all you can do is manage the symptoms,
you know,
through prison or whatever it is.
But these human predators,
um,
it's not in the religious mindset where there's a soul that there's someone good
you can get into that.
It's like you can connect with is biologically completely.
It seems to be,
again,
I'm no expert seems to be completely incorrect.
It's like saying if you've got lung cancer throughout your lungs,
that there's a healthy ghost lung that you just have to connect with the breath.
Well,
no,
your lungs are corrupted.
They're screwed up.
They're there.
They're not,
there's no healthy backup lungs.
There's no healthy backup personality or brain called the soul.
But this idea that you can reach through to the most corrupted and destroyed
people and somehow reawaken their humanity,
which is necessary for religion.
You how you have to have a soul.
I think it's really a dangerous thing because it lets us,
if you have compassion for associate pass,
they use it to manipulate and control you.
And so it's almost like if you're a sociopath,
you'd love to invent the idea of a soul so that people will try and and help you
and then you can manipulate and control them.
Whereas if you recognize it that predators,
then you just steer clear of them.
They lose a lot of their power so well it was sometimes it's very difficult to
find them.
It's very difficult to identify them.
That's one of the comedians they camouflage,
right?
Yeah.
And there's,
there's one of the ways that you can,
is by when people behave around you that seems like really fake and weird.
It's like they have like a fake weird friendship with you or fake weird
interaction with you.
One of the reasons why they have this fake weird thing is because they don't
understand regular friendships,
loves and relationships.
So it all comes off as odd to them cause they're doing make-believe all the
time.
They're,
they're imitating what they've seen around them,
they know what's important to other people,
but they don't feel that it's important to themselves.
The best way to describe it right there,
right?
Like I mean like a torturer knows what hurts you and likes it,
you know?
And they've done actually it's a bunch of studies where they show people.
Okay.
And this,
this,
I find it's sewing comprehensible.
I try and sort of get it cause having empathy for non empathetic people.
This is a tough thing.
I think it's a necessary process to go through for south protection and I think
for the betterment of the world.
So these studies where they sh they sorta hook up these,
these electrodes to people's brains.
They can measure what's going on in their brains and they show intentional
cruelty films.
Like they show like no cruelty and then accidental cruelty,
like guy steps on a rake or whatever,
right?
And then they show intentional cruelty,
like guide pretending to like stapling and other guy's hand or something like
that.
And
okay.
When people see some people see the intentional cruelty,
the same happy centers related to orgasm,
related to just feelings of intense bliss show up because this a sadist,
I'm taking pleasure in the suffering of others.
I mean that is,
that's Auntie empathy.
That's like,
well I,
you know,
I know that you're attached to your children so I'm going to use your attachment
to your children to control and bully you or whatever it is.
You know,
like you kidnap some guy's kids or whatever.
And this,
this aspect of,
of human predation is really important.
We are not a species.
We are a whole ecosystem of Predator and prey and our lack of ability to
differentiate between Predator and prey in the human species,
I think is one of the major routes of hierarchical brutalities and,
and wars and all of this kind of stuff.
And I think we really need to throw away the idea of the,
the eternal good within us and recognize that the most dangerous species to
human beings with other human beings.
By far.
I mean just governments alone in the 20th century murdered,
not even including war governments murdered 250 plus million people.
They can't even get it down to within 10 million people.
It's a quarter of a billion people murdered just by one human institution
populated by sociopaths.
These are incredibly dangerous people,
but talking about bears and stuff and that's very important.
But the most important and most dangerous predators are human beings and we
don't really have a good way of identifying them other than they're on the
ballot.
Oh sorry,
little anarchist propaganda there.
But could you imagine
if you had like a bunch of bears that were like really cool and you love to be
around them and they were like really fun and they do things for you and they
help you and help you move and do provide you with joy.
And then there's other bears that we'll just fucking eat you if they find
yeah.
Or it's like that Battlestar Galactica thing like the sidelines.
They looked like people when they're aliens.
And this is something that is,
we really got it as a species up are like radar for this kind of stuff.
Cause imagine if we could see these guys,
like if they hadn't been married,
right?
Just go home or whatever.
I get up on their psycho and then it'd be like,
okay,
well here's someone I'm not going to lend money to or be friends with or have
kids where or you know,
we could this gene or whatever.
Even if it's genetic,
we could,
we could eliminate that within a generation or two.
But as long as,
and of course if they are physically attractive or wealthy or powerful as well,
I mean they're just,
it's like Ambrosia for a lot of people,
right?
It's a,
anyway,
so this is sort of a pet thing of mine is just really help people to understand
that there are some really bad people out there.
And even if we say they don't have free will,
so what,
you know,
bears,
we don't say the bears a morally responsible for eating people,
but we don't hang out with them.
Right?
So
by that the freewheel thing,
of course you free will.
It's just like how much free will do you have?
How much decision making does your consciousness?
Huh?
If you believe you don't have freewill,
guess what?
But then there's a bunch of people,
while there's factors go that go into every decision that you make and those
factors are genetic and environmental and this and that and that.
And if you factor it all together,
it's not about freewill.
It's not about your free decision maker that maybe or maybe not.
I mean it's,
it's a very,
it's a very slippery argument both ways on both sides actually.
Yeah.
I mean for me,
because people don't say,
well defined free will and I've given some thought to it and I got a series on
youtube about this freedom in youtube.com forward slash freedom and radio people
want to check it out.
But to me,
freewill is our capacity to compare something proposed with an ideal standard.
That to me is,
is,
is really the essence of free.
So,
so composed to an ideal standard meaning that's what you gauge your reactions
and actions on.
Yeah.
So that's so science,
a proposition about the physical universe.
We compare it to an ideal standard called scientific verification or something
like that.
And more we compare a proposed action to a moral standard or a moral ideal or,
so that's the one thing we can do that nothing else in the universe that we know
of seems to be able to do to compare a proposed action.
Like,
I mean Dad's propose an action,
they all get together and they,
you know,
they all birds all fly in one direction or another and they,
but they don't compare it to an ideal.
And this,
this comparing things to an ideal I think is the fundamental aspect of our free
wheel that we have.
And we can either just go through a life and never compare anything that we do
to some ideal standard or we can say about the important things not,
you know,
do I have another sip of coffee?
But the important stuff will we compare that to some ideal standard?
And now people do this all the time,
right?
I mean,
is this moral,
is this right?
Is this God's will?
Is this with the law?
Is it against the law?
We compare a proposed actions to ideal standards in even in school.
Do you get a hundred on the test?
That's the ideal standard.
We had a 50 that's right.
No good.
So we are constantly comparing things to an ideal standard and I think that is
really the essence of choice that we have.
And even if it's not an ideal standard,
we're being inspired by what we deem to be successful behavior,
whether it's emotionally successful,
socially successful,
whatever,
career,
athletics,
whatever it is,
we,
we gain some sort of inspiration from that.
That also enhances our ability to perform the same actions.
And is that freewill to see?
Is it something else?
Is it a combination of all those things?
I think more likely that the argument that there is no freewill,
I think is a little silly because there is,
but that's not the only thing.
I think that's what it is.
I think there's a lot going on when it becomes,
when,
when you try to figure out what it is that makes a person to act,
the way they act,
we could put you in a situation and something could occur with your daughter for
say and you,
you would be like,
well,
let me explain to you what happened and let me explain to you how I've made the
same mistakes myself and this is what I learned from it.
Or You could put a different person in front of a,
a similar four year old kid and that person's going,
right.
What did I tell you?
Get your fucking hands off of that.
Come here.
Sit down.
If I've told you once,
I've told you a thousand times,
you know,
what is it that causes one to be you and one to be another person in the same
scenario with a completely different results?
Well,
it's,
no,
it's comparing two ideal standards,
right?
So in distorted that earlier where I was saying,
my daughter said,
Daddy,
I contact,
you know,
should we have a standard,
which is if someone's saying something to you,
you should really pay attention to them.
That's the standard.
Right?
And I've,
I've told her about that.
You know,
like if she's playing on the IPAD and we're trying to have a conversation,
I say,
can you turn that off while we chat?
Because,
you know,
I don't want you to be distracted.
She can make,
so there's a standard that we have.
And then when we deviate from that standard,
we've tried to realign with that standard.
And I think those are the,
basically the fundamental choices,
uh,
that we have.
What are your standards?
So some guys,
like some guys with parenting genuinely believe,
like every time I put out the facts about spanking,
I just interviewed a doctor,
Elizabeth Grimshaw for spanking expert,
who's given all the facts.
People always,
they say,
well,
you know,
but kids these days are spank glass and they were running wild and they're
having lipstick parties and they're,
you know,
hooking up and they have no more.
So they genuinely believe,
what if I don't hit my kids,
it's going to be really bad.
And I think that our futures are fundamentally written by our deepest values by
by that which we consider the good,
uh,
what your values are.
Your virtues are,
will be your future,
like a train track.
Now we can't change the effects of our ethics,
but we can decide which are valid or invalid ethics.
So I make the case that,
you know,
don't hit your kids.
Non Aggression,
principle reasoning,
better parenting,
better child development,
all the science behind it.
You're a kid's Iq will be better.
That behavior would be better than social skills will be better,
there'll be more peaceful and blah,
blah,
blah.
I make that case.
I change people's minds about that.
Like tens of thousands of of parents,
probably hundreds of thousands by now start spanking as a result of the work
that I do and there's tons of people have to do in the same work.
We give people better ideals then it's like the,
the wind changes with a boat.
It just,
they'll,
they'll turn that way.
The,
the capacity to evaluate new information and have it change our ideals I think
is the fundamental essence of that.
Uh,
of free will.
We can either choose to ignore that information,
in which case we're just going to keep doing the same thing as history,
like a hamster wheel,
a revolving door of history.
Or we can evaluate new information and change our behavior according to some new
ideal.
That I think is the only choice we have.
The people who argue against freewill only ever argue with people,
which is really interesting when you think about it cause they say people are
fundamentally indistinguishable from other complex systems like the weather.
But you never see somebody arguing with the weather.
You only ever see people debating or arguing with people.
Like had a guy call into my show recently who was telling me that he said,
Steph,
you're just like a computer.
And I said,
okay,
well why don't you here,
here's my computer.
You can continue the debate with the computer.
And he didn't understand what I was talking about.
He said,
I'm not going to talk to your computer.
I said,
so you only want to talk to me,
not the computer.
And he said,
well,
the computer doesn't understand.
I've got voice recognition.
I'll turn it on.
Go ahead.
Right.
And I said,
so you don't want to debate with the computer only with me.
So you're saying there's something different about me versus the computer and
have you ever yelled at the rain to stop raining or to change the winds
direction if it's wind is blowing the wrong way.
He said,
no,
of course not.
And I said,
so you cannot say that people are just like everything else in the universe.
If you will only ever debate people,
you have to accept that there's something fundamentally different with people if
you will never debate anything else that you compare people to.
And that's the challenge of the deterministic argument.
We are just physics.
Everything has an antecedent cause.
But you only ever debate with human beings.
That's a strange argument.
I don't understand where you're going with that.
Of course,
because human beings are the only ones that debate back.
The whole idea of a debate is you talk and they talk and you different opinions,
right?
They say that,
that you,
you debate back like two television sets pointed at each other.
It's all pre scripted.
There's nothing the new that can come in.
Everything has a prior course based on physics.
That's what people who believe that there is no freewill site.
That's what you're saying.
Yeah.
Um,
but I don't debate with the TV.
I know that the TV is going to,
you know,
I mean there are idiots who yell at movies,
but they don't demand it's going to chain bait in and of itself.
Isn't that that whole debate,
just an exchange of information and exchange in,
in a controlled system in order to humane,
but it was someone to change their mind.
Right.
Well,
I think ultimately all human beings are trying accelerate
growth.
Uh,
whether it's financial growth,
intellectual growth,
technological innovation.
I think we're constantly trying to grow and expand things.
We also fundamentally know that we are imperfect.
So we will either argue our position or try to learn,
uh,
one of those two things.
Either try to reinforce ourselves on our own decisions as opposed to your
decisions.
Jesus is the Lord and you are incorrect,
sir,
with your Satan,
Satan St and song that you teach to your daughter.
You know,
what is that about?
Well,
that is about two,
two organisms inside of a system,
uh,
that agree upon a of a dictionary,
no vocabulary and definitions for things.
And they're arguing about whose path is a better path.
But ultimately all of them are trying to be better.
All of them are trying to improve and there's no real set guidelines for how to
live correctly.
There's no,
no one can really prove to you that it's better to be an atheist than it is to
be a Christian or it's better to be a person who likes to exercise and has to be
a guy who sits on the couch.
You sort of have to figure it all out from it for yourself.
And along the way,
you want to justify your own actions and your own decisions by arguing and by,
by trying to debate.
So in a sense like saying that humans only argue with humans,
that doesn't really negate the idea that there is no free will.
In fact it might actually support it by showing the whole thing is just a system
and it is just a mathematical algorithm.
And inside that algorithm is a thing called ego.
And Ego is the thing that wants you to be correct and wants you to learn and
wants you to improve.
And once you also to assert dominance and perhaps sexual preference over those
around you by showing how clever you can turn a phrase and how easily you can
diffuse someone and make them look foolish in front of the rest of the group.
You know,
all these things are perhaps just more evidence that there is no free will.
I mean obviously playing devil's advocate a bit here,
but I think inside that controlled system,
I think it is possible that that could be,
that could be an argument.
Let's go cause you,
you said something that
it's really,
really important that that I would like to challenge.
Okay,
maybe it's successful or not,
but you said nobody can say whether it's better to believe in a day that you're
not believing a dainty and so on.
Right.
What I mean by that is that you can't tell someone who is happy being a
Christian,
that it's better to be an atheist.
They're not going to look.
I certainly can't say that you'll be happier being an atheist.
Right.
Because let's say that they're going to atheist atheism,
it's going to cause problems in their family relationships.
It's going to cause problems in their community.
It's going to cause problems in their church and then they get hit by a bus and
they die.
Unhappy.
I have friend alone
Mormon,
sorry to interrupt you.
Yeah.
I have friends who are Mormons for the longest time and then in their forties
they abandoned it rough.
They are.
They are
Penn Jillette writes about that actually.
Yeah.
And in his most recent book about meeting up with a bunch of Mormons and and how
they become atheist and just a lot of it from his work.
Yeah.
Out of his from his,
he's a great guy.
He's very logical and very smart and a lot of his questions and his,
his discussions on these things have caused introspective thought and people
that perhaps would have just gone along with the program if it wasn't for guy
like Penn.
Yeah,
I think it's very interesting.
But I,
I would make the case.
So a Nietzschean the 19th century sure sort of philosopher is sort of guy who
wrote great aphorisms,
but he said that that Socrates basic argument was reason equals virtue equals
happiness,
right?
So if you want to be happy,
you have to be virtuous.
How do you,
how are you virtuous?
You have to have con consistent principles,
consistent principles.
And there's some support in psychology for this in that if you have opposing
ideas within your own mind,
or if you have feelings that say one thing but your intellect says another,
uh,
then you are going to be unhappy.
Or another way of putting it,
it says,
say that,
uh,
all psychological dysfunction results from a unacknowledged suffering.
Um,
and so for instance,
like,
so some people,
you know,
they,
they're beaten up by their parents but they're told by their church honor thy
mother and their father.
So they've got this idea,
this ideal honor thy mother and their father,
but they have an emotional response of outrage at having been abused or
neglected or,
or whatever.
These are contradictions.
You've got an ideal that tells you one thing in your heart and your,
your monkey spleen telling you something else that if you aggress against an
animal,
it's going to react in a negative or hostile way.
And so when you have contradictions in your mind,
uh,
that is going to produce dysfunction in your life and happiness in your life.
And so one of the purposes of philosophy is to say,
okay,
we've got some basic principles.
Let's keep rolling them forward and try and live as consistently as possible.
Like if we used opposite words for things,
half the time it would be impossible to communicate.
We have to have consistency in our language to a large degree,
not perfectly.
Of course we have to have consistency in our language to be good at
communicating,
to have any possibility of communicating effectively.
And the degree to which we can have consistency in our thinking.
In other words,
we don't have contradictions.
We don't have a value here.
Like don't hit your wife and then a value here which says,
hit your children,
that that's going to produce contradictions in suffering and problems.
And so the more consistent your thinking is,
the greater chance you have to be happy.
Uh,
and in the same way,
like if you have a consistent methodology for examining the universe like
science,
you're going to get a lot further than reading chicken end trails or praying to
some nonexistent data.
You're actually going to have a way of organizing your knowledge about the world
to create computers and rocket ships and cars and all that kind of stuff.
And so the idea is that the more consistent you are thinking,
the greater chance you have for happiness.
Now,
that doesn't always mean that you'll achieve it because it's good.
Went though the way you're saying it,
the greater chance you'll have for him.
Yes,
I can.
Nobody,
nobody can guarantee anyone happiness,
right?
And,
and in fact,
if you've grown up in an irrational culture and culture is sort of by definition
is irrational.
If it's not culture,
it's science or,
or math or logic or something like that,
then when you achieve the goal of reason,
then you start working out your beliefs from first principles.
And being good at philosophy puts you in a lot of conflict with,
uh,
with people around you.
And of course,
a lot of power structure is fundamentally,
I think live or feed off an unacknowledged contradictions,
right?
So for me to,
to use force to take someone else's property is theft,
uh,
for the government to do what is called taxation and considered a virtue.
So there's all these contradictions in definitions that we have.
Uh,
we hit wives,
it's called the abuse.
We hit children,
it's called discipline.
We just redefine things all the time based upon emotional preferences and prior
trauma.
And the,
what philosophy does is it says,
well,
we've got to resolve this stuff.
We can't just have these little beliefs floating around unattached to each
other.
We need a consistent way of organizing our minds and our values and our
decisions and all of that stuff.
And we can't just make up different values based on the circumstances.
With the idea being that the more consistent you are,
the happier you'll be.
I definitely think that the last contradiction you have in your mind,
the,
the happier you'll be.
And it's really hard for a lot of people to eliminate contradiction because
they've made so many rationalizations about their actions.
It made so many rationalizations has at the past in order to shield themselves
from the staying of the,
that corrective,
the need to correct behavior,
need to correct some of the things that you've done,
that staying is very difficult for a lot of people to deal with.
So they,
they justify,
oh,
they all argue louder,
you know,
to try to,
that's,
you know,
I've got a whole series on youtube called the bomb and the brain,
uh,
which is,
um,
I don't mean to,
it's FDR,
url.com,
forward slash bib.
There's huge amount of science that,
that really establish how people argue.
How people argue is you get an emotional trigger like right deep down in your,
the base of your brain,
right?
Like where we don't know anything about civilization.
Right down in the base of our brain,
you get a fight or flight response.
And what happens then is you come up with a justification for it afterwards.
It's called ex post facto justification.
Right after the fact you have an emotional response.
And then people come up with some frankly bullshit,
some polysyllabic bullshit to justify their emotional reaction.
And they've actually done studies,
amazing stuff where
they give people a moral position and they say,
do you believe in this?
And then people say yes and they will give you great arguments as to why.
And then they say,
close the book,
I want to ask you something else.
And then the book has some special glue thing and when they open it up,
it's the opposite moral position.
And they ask people to reread that statement and defend it.
Wow.
Right?
So it says,
I oppose abortion.
And people say,
well,
here's all the reasons I oppose abortion.
They close the book,
they talk to them about something else for 50 minutes they say,
uh Oh we didn't get the recording right.
Can you open it?
And then it says,
now I oppose abortion.
And the majority of people,
like thirds of people
will give you great arguments for both and not notice the contrast.
That seems to be the key to experiencing this fight or flight feeling in the
middle of an argument is being completely attached or having your ego attached
to ideas or a position.
If you are not and you treat it as an intellectual puzzle that you can both
solve together,
then that stuff doesn't exist.
I've had some really fascinating disagreements with very close friends where
we've managed to keep it completely civil but yet explored some really
interesting topics.
But then I've also been involved in conversations with people where they get
really insulting like almost immediately if they disagree with you.
Yeah.
Like I had an argument with a dude about recent findings in,
in uh,
about the Yeti.
You know,
they,
they've found that there is a,
this thing that they thought was a Yeti,
uh,
may very well be an ancient bear or at least the DNA from an ancient bear.
We have a theme,
you know that,
right?
It's like a bear show.
The bare shots fair.
And because like bears,
I know we're going to walk out of this room.
It just be mauled.
I did some,
some freak escaped from the zoo thing and this is going to be hugely ironic
podcasts.
What was fascinating to me in the middle of this heated argument was not that
this guy disagreed with my,
my thoughts that uh,
this whole thing was probably a big misunderstanding.
And there's probably some strange looking bear it looks like,
but it was how aggressive like someone would get about a fucking Yeti.
Like you're raising your voice and you're getting shitty in real snipey and like
this is not the way you should get ever with your friends.
And you're getting this over a fucking Yeti.
Yeah.
If it's over the ethics of violence or something that's at least an important
topic.
But whether there's big foot or not.
Well,
not only that,
it was,
oh man,
it was over a fucking DNA evidence.
I mean,
this is all pretty straightforward stuff.
Like,
you know,
they've found that there's some,
some what they thought was extinct,
polar bear,
some hybrid type of polar bear.
This,
they thought it was extinct for 40,000 plus years and they've got DNA that came
from something that was killed a long time ago,
probably,
I think it was in 1900 or something.
And they say,
oh,
well this,
this thing matches up with this,
this DNA,
what we might be dealing with when these people were seeing Yeti's.
It's actually just polar bears.
Right.
You know,
it's really simple,
right?
It's just an idea and it's just,
I don't,
I didn't do the fucking research.
He didn't do the fucking research.
So like getting upset about it.
It's so weird.
But,
but that's what it is.
It's,
it triggers that fight or flight thing.
And then once they realize they're in some sort of a debate and perhaps they
don't engage in enough competition,
perhaps they don't engage enough athletic endeavors where they strain their body
and get rid of some of that fucking monkey shoes.
It used to failure and he used to losing.
That's another thing that's,
it's some people do not like to lose at anything.
Like they won't even,
they won't bowl because if they lose,
they get sick.
You know,
they,
they won't play checkers.
They won't do anything.
But that's,
I mean it's crazy.
Isn't that always just childhood stuff Joe?
I mean this is that just people,
you know,
they don't like to admit that they're wrong because whenever they would admit
that they're wrong,
there would be mocked or humiliated
that happens in school all the time.
Like I had a guy in a friend of mine,
uh,
in,
in junior high school,
we were in science class and he used the word orgasm instead of organism.
I don't even remember the sentence,
which is a shame cause I bet you it was a really great sentence because anytime
you put the word orgasm into a sentence inadvertently,
it's funny.
Yeah,
I think it's premature elaboration is the phrase.
But anytime you did that,
it's funny.
But literally for the whole year he was the calm guy.
Like he was,
he was the orgasm guy.
And it's like how comfortable do you feel making stupid mistakes like that?
If that is the environment that you're in,
then you're just not going to like families will so often stereotype people.
Like you drop three plates and then for the next 50 years you're the clumsy one.
You know?
And then you become paranoid about all this kind of stuff.
Yes.
And it becomes something that's in the forefront of your mind.
Don't drop the plates
and then it becomes a self fulfilling prophecy because then people don't
remember the million times you carried a plate successfully,
but 20 years later you drop a plate.
It's like,
oh well he's the clumsy one and people hate beast.
I hate being stereotyped like that.
And if you carry that idea in your head,
it does create weight and it gets momentum behind it.
It's with everything.
Like if you're playing basketball,
don't miss a shot.
Don't miss your shot.
What are you thinking about?
You thinking about missing the shot?
You don't even think about making it.
You're thinking about missing it more than you thinking about making it.
You're feeling the failure already before you even attempted it,
because it's become a predominant pattern in your way of thinking.
Yeah.
I wouldn't,
I mean,
I'd love to know,
you know,
like the twins experiments that someone,
I would love to know which parts of me are me and which part of media or
environment or which part of me of genetics,
like put me somewhere else.
I know.
I mean,
that'd be fascinating
because,
but it's not,
I mean,
you are a series of events that have taken place over 46 years of life and 24
hours in a day and 365 days in a year and just blah so much.
There's so many calculations.
And here's the interesting question to you because you predominantly,
uh,
ply your trade on the Internet,
how much of an impact has the Internet had on who you are as a person?
Just the,
the free flowing of information over the last 20 years.
Since we're the same age.
Thinking of nine 94 ish.
Yeah.
Where,
where it really popped out.
How much of an impact has it had on you?
Oh,
it's,
it's
big.
I know it is.
It is.
If I were to look at,
I mean other than learning how to read it,
it's the biggest influence and impact.
I mean,
I'm only able to do what I do because of the Internet because the gatekeepers
are gone.
Like we can talk to people without gatekeepers.
That is like the last time this happened in in such a fundamental way was like
in the 16th century when Martin Luther translated the Bible from Latin to the
vernacular and then people got to get their hands on the Bible verse before it
was all done in in Latin and nobody knew what the hell was going on other than
like the priest told them they got a hold of the Bible and basically the tax
could speak directly to people and didn't have to go through gatekeepers
anymore.
The unfortunate result of that was a couple of hundred years of religious
warfare,
which then again culminated in a separation of church and state because they
just were killing each other and Lutherism and Lutheranism ends when gay elitism
and Calvinism and Anabaptism and all that kind of stuff and a baptism where you
have to have an adult baptism.
Do you know how they did dealt with this in Germany?
Oh,
you're an Anabaptist will drown you because you just into adult baptism.
I mean it was just brutal.
One of the reasons that the Nazis had such power was the Germany missed the
whole enlightenment because they were just so embroiled in religious warfare.
I mean there's travelers who went through Germany in the 17th and 18th century
and said,
you could barely see a tree without the fruit of a hanging person on it.
I mean,
it was that insanely violent society based upon religious dogma.
And so they,
they not system.
It's like this weird medieval isn't that made it through the renaissance and the
enlightenment in Germany.
Uh,
and,
and then had the power of the 20th 20th century technology with all the
brutality of a medieval parenting and,
and uh,
brutalities.
So anyway,
a lot of the strict discipline as well for the,
the military discipline,
the goose stepping,
all that came from Oh and hit the screaming.
Alice Miller has written great stuff about this.
Like a Hitler was,
was beaten so badly.
He actually went into a coma at once.
He was beaten so badly and was,
I mean he was just so,
and the kids,
they would hang their babies on hooks in,
in swift,
in bandages that often would have licensed them.
Then the lights would crawl all over the baby's skin and lay eggs.
And so when he referred to the Jews as Lyse,
it,
it connected with something so primal in the German psyche.
And I tell you this though,
the Germans learned an incredible lesson from that.
My mom is German and when I grew up,
my cousins would come to visit from Germany.
And of course we were idiot warmonger British boys.
Cause you know we won the war,
right?
Which meant we lost to socialism,
but we,
we won the war.
And so we were all playing word games.
And my German friends,
cousins would come over and they'd say,
well,
we were not allowed to play with guns.
We're not allowed to do any of that stuff.
Because they did finally get,
you know,
I hope we get this book for some other stupid cataclysm on the planet.
They finally got that they needed to change their parenting if they didn't want
this crazy stuff to continue.
There's a book I'm reading as an audio book by Lloyd demoss called the origins
of war in child abuse.
It's actually available for free,
uh,
freedom and radio.com where he says,
basically,
if you want to know where war comes from,
a,
you have to focus on child abuse status,
where all of this stuff gets laid in a,
and this is,
you can,
they've done a huge number of studies.
Robin grills written a book called parenting for a peaceful world where he
traces,
you know,
you can tell how quickly a democracy comes to a country by how the prevalence
banking is.
I mean,
there's incredible things like all politics to me is an effect of,
of early family experiences of early childhood experiences.
And to try and understand how hierarchies can exist without looking at early
childhood experiences is impossible.
It's like trying to,
to run the solar system model without putting the sign in the middle.
It gets ridiculously complicated and,
and,
and so on.
So,
um,
yeah.
So I think that's one of the reasons why I continue to focus on this.
You started with the question about the Internet and it did,
it's being able to talk directly to people without gatekeepers is an incredible
experience.
Uh,
and,
and is the greatest leap forward I think,
in,
in human communication and,
and the possibility of,
of virtue I think is,
is unbelievably enhanced by this.
I agree with you.
And A,
I also agree with you that I,
I am unrecognizable to myself of the past because of the Internet.
And I think my,
my understanding,
tell me,
I mean,
you've got one of the biggest shows around.
that would that have happened without
no,
no.
I mean,
no,
it's impossible.
It would've never happened.
I would never been able to do this.
I would have been fired a long time ago.
There's no way I would've been able to do any of the things that I've done
online with,
with some sort of accompany backing it and saying,
this is a good idea.
No one would have said it's a good idea.
No,
no,
no.
Publicist would have said it's a good idea to say the things that I've said.
No,
no agent would have advised me to move in that direction.
Wouldn't have happened.
It happened naturally.
It happened on its own.
But I think that the biggest impact for me is not that I've been able to express
myself,
but that other people have been able to send me information,
express themselves to me,
the impact of being able to share information online,
store even wrong things.
Like there's a mean that there's a video that went around that it has gotten
massive traction in the past few days.
It was a man who was a on the news and didn't know the camera was on,
didn't know that his microphone was on and he was talking about a missing girl
and he was saying,
you know that uh,
hey,
if he finds her I would fuck her.
Fuck her right in her pussy hole.
Like,
but it was fake.
And then you see the newscaster go,
we're sorry for that unfortunate thing.
But that newscaster was from a previous thing where a woman didn't know that her
microphone was on and dropped an f bomb,
just said,
fuck,
oh fuck.
And so I'm sorry,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're having some editorial.
We were very sorry that you know,
editing issues.
Very sorry.
You had to hear that.
Well,
this video has gone viral and it's millions and millions of,
and I don't,
can't tell you how many people sent it to me on Twitter,
but we're going a couple of days.
It resolves itself and people realize,
oh,
it's just bullshit.
Okay,
here we go.
So wait,
how is it fake?
Was it
fake?
It's just an actor.
So I pretended and spliced it in.
He put his footage of him saying this horrible thing,
but it wasn't really a missing girl.
It was all fake and fake Fox broadcast label and all that shit.
It gets exposed.
It does get exposed and that's what,
that's what's unique about the times.
And it's also that something can just spread.
It just has to be impactful and interesting,
whether good or bad.
I mean that's,
it's an incredible thing which is happening in America as well,
where you can actually see bodies of imperialism,
right?
Like you,
you can go online and you can see the bodies of the Iraqis or the bodies of the
Afghanis or whatever.
That's,
I mean,
you'd never get that through the media.
not only that,
it was made illegal during the Bush administration in the United States.
She'll show coffins,
coffins,
let alone the victims of the imperialism and the media.
I mean,
there's no law that says you can't show Iraqi,
uh,
victims of the war,
which there are over a million.
But nonetheless,
you will not get this through the mainstream media.
You'll see the pictures of the guys who died,
which is also a great tragedy.
The American soldiers who've died,
but you can't see this and you,
you can't find out the basic fact that there has been so much radiation damage
down to the Iraqis,
particularly in Fallujah,
that up to a third of children are being born with birth defects.
That people who've gone to study Iraqi cities where these depleted uranium
shells have been used.
Say that they've never seen a more genetically compromised,
genetically ruined population,
the whole world over.
And the fact that this information is available at the click of a button to me
means that people no longer have the excuse of having been propagandized,
you know,
some poor bastard who,
who was in a Stalinist Russia,
you know,
in the 1950s,
okay,
be a communist or go to the Gulag,
you know,
uh,
that,
that's your choice.
So he,
he's a communist,
but you don't say you're a communist by choice,
then it's just like the way you,
it's like you're in the Hitler youth.
You're a Nazi,
but you're not a bad kid because you're an Nancy.
That's just what you have to do a to survive in the culture.
But now that information is so available,
nobody can claim any more,
at least in the West that they didn't know.
Uh,
because it's so immediately available to everyone at all times that if you don't
know now,
it is an act of choice.
It is not the result of propaganda.
I have a lot more sympathy,
like a woman called in my show the other day.
Then she said,
you know,
and my dad beat me and my mom didn't do anything about it.
And a mom grew up under China under Mao and the cultural revolution where people
were dropping like flies every time they bad at their eyelids wrong.
As a great story in Salto needs into the Gulag apical Argo where some minor
party functionary has given a speech and everyone gets up and is applauding and
they're also terrified of being the first person to stop applauding that they
just keep applauding and keep applauding until their hands look like hamburgers
and they can't even like,
it's so incredible,
but nobody wants to stop because the first person who stops his art a comrade,
you seem to be less enthused and they're just terrified.
This is the world that some people live in.
We don't have that world here in the west and we have access to every kind of
information,
opposing viewpoints.
You can go on to Al Jazeera,
you can find out what American imperialism or British imperialism looks like or
even Canadian imperialism in Afghanistan looks like from the other side.
So there's a great ripping away of the excuse of propaganda and ignorance and a
great settling of moral responsibility on people.
Yeah,
it's a very unique time as far as exposing evil and distributing information of
very,
very unique time.
I don't think there's ever been anything like it and I think uh,
you and I are both two perfect examples and also that we can find each other and
be able to do this.
I mean this what,
what,
how would,
if this,
how would have
our friendship happened?
How would it,
we have had these three hour conversations.
Even if we,
if we didn't have podcasts and we got to meet each other,
we would have to agree to sit down and talk for three hours and then it's like,
who would benefit from that?
You and I would certainly benefit from it.
We would enjoy it,
but no one else would get it.
It's not,
it's not like something that would just get out to millions and millions of
people like almost instantaneously forever and grow constantly.
Last show went to number one on iTunes.
Yeah.
Like I was expecting that to happen cause my rap sucks.
So that's really great that we're doing this cause my music career remains
stilled in the doldrums.
Yeah.
But I think that it is an incredible opportunity.
It's like,
you know,
we've got this,
this,
I do a lot of talk about bitcoin and stuff like that where we have the
opportunity to have a currency system not controlled by governments.
You know,
where there's ways of,
I mean these things are just unbelievable opportunities for,
for human communication that doesn't have to go through the prescribed channels
and the prescribed gatekeepers and ways of exchanging value.
I mean,
you can have a,
an IPO,
I don't know it in bitcoin.
You can have an IPO and you can start a company without having to spend $4
million on,
on,
uh,
the,
all of the accountants and lawyers that are needed from an IPO in the west.
I mean the things like that just a incredible,
because we have got to get faster at getting better as a species because our
technology is going through the roof.
Human knowledge is doubling every 18 months.
Weapons that are inconceivable to to even a generation or two ago are a readily
available [inaudible] and three d printers and surveillance technologies.
I mean,
God,
every time we come up with something good,
the assholes take it and use it against us.
Doesn't that drive you crazy?
It's like every time you pull out a gun to fight the mugger the Maga dose like
this and he has the gun,
it's like,
dammit,
can't we have technology that isn't put to the service of assholes?
We have to get faster at getting better as a species because our technology is
increasing to the point where if we don't get better quickly,
I don't think we're going to have much luck staying free.
Well,
I think we're,
we are getting better and I think it is,
we are trying to catch up to this technological capability that we find
ourselves in right now,
but I think we are.
I really do.
I really,
I mean it's not just hollow optimism.
I really do believe that we are getting better.
I think that we're commenting on the fact that it's not perfect and I think
everybody is,
and I think Glenn Greenwald and all of these different Edward Snowden and
others,
people exposing all of the hypocrisy and government and all the,
all of that is working towards what ultimately will be a very unique time in
history when they look back at this time,
the birth of the Internet will be by far one of the biggest events in the
history of the human race and we'll look at all these different growing phases
and all these different challenging events that happen and we won't,
we won't see it as much because we were a part of it right now,
but I think things are just changing.
People are more responsible for their actions.
People are more educated,
information flows far more freely than ever before.
It's happening.
It's all happening right now.
But I don't know about you.
I mean,
I know that a lot what you do is about getting
information out to people and I think that's great.
I do off of the things that there's a lot of ethics behind what it is that you
do because it's not like you get a whole bunch of KKK members on here
proselytizing about white nationalism.
I think you try to get people with good and useful a few points,
even if it's just mentally stimulating that promotes virtue as well.
For me,
I really feel a sense of urgency and I try not to let it,
you know,
make every day like a race against evil or something like that.
But I,
you know,
the,
the technology of control and surveillance and all of that is,
is growing so quickly.
I really do feel like the same medium that is,
can be capable of so much control and surveillance is also what we're using to
communicate.
I feel quite a strong urgency that it's,
it's a race of us versus them.
Uh,
and,
and this is why I have like 3000 shows.
I mean,
it's,
it's lunatic,
right?
But I really do feel cause remember freedom in radio where quantity is quality,
but I really,
well,
you're selling yourself short.
You have a lot to say to me.
You can do 3000 shows because you have 3000 shows where the things you say
you're not trying 3001 with this because if this is the last show,
without going to understand that we're good.
Do you feel,
do you feel that there is,
I don't feel it's inevitable that the good people when I think that's a lot to
do with really working at,
at getting the message out.
I think there's a battle.
I think there always is and I think that battle exists because you need a yen to
have a Yang.
You need a push and a pull.
You need an eval and a good.
Do you need an ideal to subscribe to or aspire to when you also need a really
negative thing to avoid?
I've learned personally from the failures of other people and I think that's an
important lesson that you've learned from people who've gotten hooked on drugs.
I've learned from people who have ruined their life because of alcoholism or
gambling or whatever the fuck it's been.
I the,
these are all there also as life lessons and it's a very,
very,
very fascinating trip that we're on.
Um,
I do have a sense of urgency,
but for the most part it's really a sense of stimulation and excitement and have
just really excited about,
I like to fight.
Yes.
I think that if I'd been born later,
it wouldn't have been as much fun.
I like being in the fight where it is now because it seems so overwhelming,
you know?
I mean,
what if we got two microphones and,
and uh,
one bad haircut and one great Polish?
Well,
we're,
we're in the craziest time that human being has ever existed in and trying to
figure as far as like technology and information trying to figure our way
through this.
You're going to get these things like the NSA surveillance issue.
You're going to get that.
And when you find out that they're building this gigantic facility in Utah to
store all the information that slowly but surely it gets out.
They've already started doing it,
and then you know,
all of this capability remotely,
I phoned and they have a hundred percent control of it.
They could turn your camera on,
they could turn your phone on.
You don't even see it.
You don't even know it's on.
And it can be explored.
Node.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
Amber Lyon told us that when she went to other countries,
they wouldn't let anybody talk to them.
If they had an iPhone,
you had to have an android of some other phone where they could remove the
battery or they wouldn't talk to you.
Wow.
They were like,
what do you think?
We're stupid?
Get that.
Fuck.
I'm crazy.
Spy device out of here.
Like there's no such thing as an iPhone to them.
That's a spy device.
You've got to have a phone.
We can remove the battery and sit down where we know that you're not
transmitting this conversation to some nefarious source across the world,
which is what they can do.
That is also a part of this weird thing that we're doing.
But ultimately my thoughts are that if I look at the accountability,
here's the perfect example.
Look at General Petraeus.
General Petraeus got caught and removed as the head spy from that CIA being
investigated by the FBI.
I mean the FBI found out that he was having this affair and all this jazz with
the reporter or the woman who wrote the book about him,
but why?
How did that happen?
It was cyber.
It happened through the very thing that we're all scared of where everyone is
scared of someone being able to go into your email and find,
oh look,
Stefan Molyneux a,
apparently he's gone to these communist meetings and he wanted his find out what
it's all about.
We have some information that maybe you've been thinking about overthrowing the
government and then boom,
you're in jail.
Like,
look,
I was just talking to,
he was a theoretical ideas.
He's just,
I,
I'm,
I'm an anarchist,
but not really young.
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not raising dones or anything.
This is what happened to the head spoons.
Oh yeah,
no,
I,
when someone calls in my my show and they say that the name's Jack,
I don't say hi to them.
I would say,
Hi Jack.
Nope,
nope.
I say high listener hijack is,
Oh,
you gotta get red flags.
And I,
I still do it,
but I'm like,
I'm,
I'm conscious of the fact that,
you know,
when I say something is the bomb,
this could be pink,
you know,
it could be flagged and Microsoft and Skype or you know,
in deep with these guys and it's,
you know,
it is there.
I mean,
we do have to struggle through this stuff and I don't feel particularly a
concern.
I think I hit like with three or 4 million downloads a month,
I think I've hit enough trajectory that,
you know,
I just can't be targeted in that kind of way very easily anymore.
But yeah,
definitely at the beginning there was a little bit of,
Oh,
I'm still pretty small.
And it's also,
you have the ability to be honest and express yourself.
You can't be like,
you can't be silenced in the McCarthy era.
How did you get your,
if you know the,
they came after you and said you were a communist and you got kicked out of,
you know,
whatever job you were doing,
what are you going to do?
Are you going to start a blog and we're going to do it and you're going to get
on it on fucking Twitter and explain yourself and 140 characters now you
couldn't do a damn thing right now.
You know,
if you have a situation where perhaps maybe something comes out where you did
say something that you regretted or you did do something in the past that maybe
wasn't the best,
you could describe it in depth and a show own it and it wouldn't be,
it would be a complete nonissue and in fact you'd probably grow from this non
issue and the listeners would grow from the experience of hearing you honestly
talk about whatever it is,
whether it's,
you know,
going to some fucking communist meeting.
I mean obviously that's not an issue.
Now I'm giving McCarthyism terms,
but whatever it could be,
that would be something that they could hold over you.
And it's almost,
it doesn't anymore.
You know,
it almost doesn't batter.
And I believe that where this is heading is a time,
whether it's a decade,
two,
three,
what have you,
where there are no secrets and it's probably beginning to be some sort of a
technological change.
And the way we exchange information,
maybe it's some Google glass thing that goes to the next level and becomes an
implant or whatever the fuck it is.
I really don't think there's going to be any secrets.
I think we're going to laugh one day at the times.
We used to be able to lie to people.
We're going to laugh at the time she used to be able to tell people that you're
going to go to some place,
but really you went to some other place.
There's not going to be that anymore.
That,
that,
that your whereabouts.
We'll just be information and it's easy to look as a,
as a Google search.
Well,
I,
I think that,
uh,
that's in real benefits of that,
you know,
that there's a whole bunch of lawyers who are now trying to subpoena the NSA for
data that will exonerate their clients hopefully,
where they had cell phone records or something that will helpfully exonerate
their clients and so on.
I mean,
I personally would be more than willing to give up where I'm going and what I'm
doing and so on to an organization that was actually there to sort of help them
protect me.
I mean,
I was just reading on,
on the drudge report the other day,
I think it was the,
it was the FBI or the CIA have just scrubbed from their mission plan,
anything to do with criminal,
like pursuing criminals.
Now.
It's just been entirely basically protecting the powers that be,
that's so crazy.
Really.
It's natural though.
I mean the scrambling for control.
Well look,
the police have no duty per to protect.
That's been shown many,
many times.
You have no constitutional right to a jury before the trial of your peers
because what is it?
95% of people never get a jury trial in the United States because all they do is
they get threatened with insane sentences and they just plead down.
I mean,
because there's just,
you have no hope.
I mean,
they've even said that,
that,
that I'm threatening someone with a life sentence for a minor transgression,
uh,
in there getting to deplete for something less while threatening them with a
life sentence for a minor transgression of the law is not cruel and unusual
punishment.
Uh,
it is,
it is.
You can't bribe someone with 50 bucks,
uh,
in the legal system,
but you can bribe them with reducing something from 20 years to two years and
somehow 18 years is not a bribe.
So there is no constitutional right to a trial.
There's almost nobody,
particularly in drug stuff.
I mean,
people just plead down and go to jail.
Uh,
and a lot of these people are convicted on the hearsay of other people who
themselves are giving up,
whoever they knew in order to get out of crazy jail time and so on.
So it is a,
it is a monstrous system right now.
I mean,
this comes back to the whole war on drug stuff,
which is just,
I mean,
so amazingly evil that it's,
it staggers the imagination.
I mean,
I can't believe,
and it's so fantastic that that America's find,
they're looking over to the example of Portugal,
Portugal 10 years ago,
decriminalize their drugs and now they have a 50% reduction in drug use and they
actually get addicts help.
Addicts should get help.
It's a medical problem.
They need,
you know,
let's say it's not medical that they got in there,
but so what they're in there,
right?
I mean even drunk drivers needed the jaws of life to get out of a car and,
and they,
they get these people,
the medical help they need and they don't throw people in jail.
Personal consumption of mind altering substances.
Like TV isn't one of those.
And they actually get people help,
but now they're starting to get a couple of things here and there where you can
go and buy this stuff legally and so on.
I mean,
thank God.
I,
I thought we were going to be so past what it used to be like before the war on
drugs that people like,
at least with prohibition,
it was only what,
13 or 14 years in the 30s with prohibition and even that brought organized crime
over to America.
I thought we'd,
we'd have this war on drugs for so long that people would be,
would have forgotten what it was like beforehand and it would have just gone on
forever.
But it does look like there is going to be some relaxation of this stuff.
Some tentative steps are being taken towards it.
And my God,
what an incredible thing,
uh,
that that's happening because I mean,
the majority of people in prison are there for completely nonviolent offenses.
Do you know the what the,
what they did in Colorado with the,
uh,
legal marijuana,
you're allowed to buy it and sell it.
Retail was the first guy who bought,
right?
Yes.
That was the first co Bot and one day they went,
they made over $1 million.
The first day 12 stores made over a million dollars in Colorado.
Wow.
And by the way,
that money is going to be taxed and it's going to be going back to the people
and that's going to benefit people.
That stimulates the economy.
It's actually good and it makes people nicer.
And so it was going to come a lot of people down.
Well,
if people in a more sensitive mood
so much,
I mean,
let's say you could just legalize all this stuff tomorrow,
what an incredible thing it would be.
First of all,
there'd be less incentive.
One,
one of the reasons people get hooked a is because people offer them free drugs
because it's so profitable once they are hooked,
it's also forbidden.
So it seems it's enticing.
And one of the things about Holland that's been so fascinating is that they're
hard drug use is a radically down because cannabis is so prevalent in and
accepted.
Did that just so I actually going to go speak in Amsterdam,
I'm speaking to with this huge crowd and Amsterdam about cryptocurrencies in,
in April,
I think it's called don't sweat currencies,
bitcoin and stuff like corn yet.
Why is that crypto?
Oh,
because it's encrypted.
It's anonymous.
It's,
you know,
it's not open clear text.
It was like secret.
What kind of secret?
Right.
In that you just,
you can't be identified if you take some basic steps in,
in your economic transactions and what a blessing that is for a lot of people,
even people who are doing the right stuff,
like a third of the world's economy,
a third of the whole world's economy is black or gray market.
It's huge.
Crazy.
It is.
When people find out that that was a major motivation for the Vietnam War,
the in you,
that's another thing that you can find out on the internet today is how much
money was being made by selling heroin.
People don't even want to believe that.
They're like,
oh,
come on.
You really think that heroin had a lot to do with the Vietnam War for the people
who are selling and it's certainly fun and those people made millions of
dollars,
right?
Like what do you think?
Where did that all go?
Did that all just disappear and did it turn into a mist?
Was it like the super soaker and the 41 below zero air?
Like what the fuck happened?
What happened to all that
peace in Afghanistan?
The people think that the poppies in Afghanistan and completely irrelevant to
the Watson anyway,
it's a whole,
well it's,
yeah,
it's a fascinating subject because people automatically want to dismiss it
because of the war on drugs because it's not
thought of as a commodity.
It's instead thought of as something that's illegal and,
and you just gross and look,
oh drugs,
drugs,
drugs are money and money is what everybody wants.
And these fucking people that are over there that are trying to extract
resources,
whether it's in the form of natural gas or whether it's in the form of oil,
that same type of thinking.
If you think that that same type of thinking doesn't agree or doesn't,
doesn't work in terms of like trying to make similar amounts of money from
illegal drugs,
you're crazy.
And it's,
it's so naive
and drugs are a fantastic way to harass the population.
You know,
because the whole idea behind common law is that the law is passive.
Like the law doesn't go out looking for problems.
You know,
like if you,
if you come key my car,
then I call up the cops and then like,
because you've done me wrong,
you know,
the law leaps into action.
The law is never supposed to exist without a complaint.
Right.
And if you know,
you buy drugs from some guy and you like the drugs and he likes your money,
there's no complaint,
but the law then becomes proactive and it goes out there looking for problems
and nobody's complaining.
And that's when the law becomes tyrannical.
When the law is passive and just waits for a complaint and it has clear rules.
Ah,
okay.
That's a fairly good thing.
When the law goes from reactive to proactive and starts going out there to look,
oh,
prostitution or gambling or drugs,
you know,
this is all voluntary consensual stuff.
You know,
it may not be healthy and excess,
but neither are cheesecakes who gives a shit.
Right.
How about the fact that people are being arrested now for having secret
compartments in their car?
Yeah,
I read about that.
Yeah.
Not even having drugs,
having zero drugs,
but having a secret compartment in their car.
Your you,
they can strip your car down,
search it.
Even if they find nothing,
they're not in trouble.
Well then they get the,
they get these stupid drug sniffing dogs that completely retarded.
I mean like,
well did you find something like,
Oh did you find something that dog starts going like this because of the tone of
voice of the cop and they suddenly think that this is somehow some
justification.
[inaudible] they're actually very good at training dogs to find drugs
encouraged by the policeman who wants to harass them.
Ray can be if they're trained poorly,
but if they react in a very strong women taught their,
their sense of smell is impossible for us to even fathom.
They put up with people I can be because so bad like a how they got to love us
something fierce,
you know,
cause we think it's hell.
We think of smells a bad thing and they don't,
they sniff other dogs.
Shit bothered them.
Maybe that's why they love us as we smelled like shit,
I didn't like that.
But dogs can actually smell cancer.
They can take files.
Yeah.
They've trained dogs.
They've taken vials of tissue and have cancerous tissue in certain vials and had
a whole row of the many,
many,
many choices.
And there's dawn who went down the road and went right to it over and over again
so they can actually smell cancer on people.
They can smell sick people.
Wow.
I did.
Yeah,
we did.
We can't even,
I mean,
they can smell fear.
They can smell adrenaline rushes,
they can smell.
When you're thinking about doing something,
there's a lot of reasons to have those.
Those senses,
the senses of smell.
I mean,
animals have them in a very,
very strong way.
If animals smell you in the woods,
they fucking run.
I mean,
they smell you.
They know your intentions almost.
I mean,
there's information that comes out in your scent that we just,
our noses are stupid or knows it.
Oh,
I was pot roast.
I smell gas.
You know,
I know this isn't broken.
There's so clumsy.
A great analogy for,
for how incompetent our noses are in comparisons to a dog is skunks.
Because we can smell skunk sent in one part per billion.
We can smell skunk sent a little bit of spray whey the fuck down the block and
we be like,
what is that?
That's how a dog is for everything.
Dog can smell everything like that.
They can smell all kinds of things and tiny amounts of it in the air and the
weekend they'd find people in the woods.
Man.
I run through the woods and a dog knows where the guy went based on his body
touching the ground in certain places and it's your fucking shoe and your sh how
much scent is your shoe giving off?
But the dog can smell that and find you.
Would you have off?
I've thought about this sometimes I was like,
I was just,
I,
I went to exercise before the show and so my wife was laying out some stuff
cause she,
you know,
has a better clothing sense.
I'd be here and like a mess t shirt and like this.
Yeah,
something like that.
Caveman coffee.
And I was thinking,
which is if you could like just,
I don't know,
like 10 seconds in someone else's consciousness,
do you think that would be like the most oh 10 seconds in a dog's brain?
I think it would just be like if I could do that and come back and not be
insane.
I think I,
you know,
we were talking about,
I would totally do that.
Like if I could sit there in my wife's brain for 10 seconds or half day or
whatever,
I think that would be so amazing.
You know,
to just with her experience is different than mine and other species.
I could love it to be in a shark's brain to be in it.
I just,
if I could do that and come back and not be completely mental and,
but still retain the memory of it.
I don't know.
It's kind of an idle thought,
but I think it would be really,
really fascinating.
They should do,
they should,
if they do ever come up with that technology,
they should force it on the people at seaworld and get killer whales mind and
stick it in a person.
And to have them by your Larson's leg off.
Oh,
just have them.
If I didn't like herring so much.
You bastard.
What kind of torture their their existing in a daily basis.
Yeah.
Make them,
make them do it and see if they come back and still want to run seaworld.
Oh I dunno.
Or zoos or anything like that.
Zeus we have to have,
cause it's the only place you will let Komodo dragons exists.
Oh,
Sue's rich guy's yard.
Some rich guys got a big fucking big fence.
Big Komodo size like barbecue there for special guests.
Right.
Well this is my thoughts on,
on animals.
You know,
I've always said I,
I do love nature much as you do
spec nature.
I'm,
I find it absolutely beautiful and fascinating.
Amazing.
And I talk about wolves and bears and all this different shit like as if I hate
them all,
but I'm absolutely thrilled that they exist.
I find it amazing.
But one of the things that people who are more interested in animals and they
are people,
I mean there's a,
there's a lot of animal lovers that say just unbelievably things.
Sometimes
we can't find cures for childhood cancers because of bunnies like they give,
you can't test off on bunny,
you know,
these are the people whose kids have never been sick.
You know,
like,
I don't care how many bunnies it takes.
Make my,
I mean,
sorry,
you know,
I have a little bit more allegiance to the,
genetic closeness a,
I think there is,
um,
a bit too much.
I think you know,
a bit too much that way.
I mean,
human life is still pretty significant relative to animals
and you know,
on people.
I've always been on Ted team by pen.
It doesn't mean I hate the other teams,
but if the shit goes down,
I'm with the people.
Rabid start fucking running through the streets,
killing babies.
I'm shooting rabbit,
you know?
Absolutely.
It's real simple.
I'm not going to say,
well,
you know,
they were here first.
You know that all,
you can totally sell tickets to your dreams because you know,
you're going to dream about that tonight.
Like you had that dream about giving roses at the guy.
Now you could have a dream about rabbits running through the streets,
killing people.
It's possible.
It's very possible.
Dammit.
Buddies.
Well,
I've had,
I've had many,
many animal dreams.
Um,
I have a,
a vast amount of respect for animals and I've also been around them.
I've seen a couple of mountain lions.
I've been around a lot of coyotes.
Coyotes are the creepiest fuckers ever.
You know,
I was in my yard the other day,
uh,
and uh,
I think it was a coyote.
It might've been a mount line,
but something was chasing a deer and I just randomly happened to be there when
it happened and this deer was fucking big,
you know,
like,
maybe a hundred plus pounds,
whatever it was,
because I could hear it running and I'm outside.
It's two o'clock in the morning.
I'm just chilling outside and I just happened to be really close to this
happening.
So this animal just fucking runs through white eyes and all that.
Yeah,
I didn't see it.
I saw a silhouette because it was really dark out,
but it was fucking running and it was heavy and behind.
It was something chasing it,
something,
trying to eat it and I appreciate it was a coyote.
And when I see,
when I just feel that and hear that and know that like I find it thrilling.
I find it fascinating,
but I also find it quite terrifying.
That's the food chain.
There's something about as big as me and it's running away from something about
as big as me.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
if grass could make horror movies,
they'd all be called the deer,
you know,
at the fucking cows.
You know?
He didn't even kill him.
He just bit the top of his head bleeding and screaming and some ripped out by
the roots.
Yup.
Monstrous.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
100% I said,
I think we're out of time.
I think we,
we,
yeah,
we just,
she had rushed through it.
Yeah.
We didn't talk about it.
A lot of things that I wanted to talk about quick.
Definitely.
It always feels quick,
man.
Yeah.
I could tell him,
I said,
tell my girlfriends,
you know,
it's longer than it feels.
These conversations are fascinating.
You know,
they,
they do feel quick.
They go by,
but three hours seems to be the right amount.
You don't have any like chat room because people are watching.
They've watched his life.
Yeah.
This is live on Ustream right now.
It's ustream.tv forward slash Joe Rogan.
It's live right now.
So there,
there's a bunch of people watching it live.
More people will catch it on Youtube,
but the most we'll see it,
uh,
either as an MP three relative to the last show.
This has delicious buttery audio.
Yeah,
there's more deliciousness to it for sure.
Had some caveman coffee with butter last time we were stuck in downtown Toronto
to put in a pitch for the Stevia.
Is that,
that is like cocaine from my sugar.
Tea is my sweet tooth.
That is just fantastic.
It's not dangerous.
It's not,
I mean,
you'd need a tiny amount of it to sweeten things as well.
And it doesn't spike your sugar doesn't fuck with your insulin levels.
It's actually not bad for you.
Yeah.
Listen,
man,
we got to do this more often.
I really enjoyed this very much.
I'll be back here and watch.
Maybe we do another one.
Fuck yeah.
Down Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you sir.
Thank you.
So a lot of fun.
Even more fun than the last one.
Um,
and you can catch Stefan online if free domain,
radio.com.com FDR,
you were l.com forward slash iTunes for my feed.
And you might as well give my,
I'm sure most of my listeners know your feet as well,
but free domain radio is your eye,
your uh,
your iTunes feed.
Uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
FDR,
url.com,
forward slash free made radio.
We'll get people to the iTunes feed.
It's a redirect and you have a vast amount of,
of,
of content out there and incredible amounts and uh,
all that sort of stuff.
So I hope people will check it out to videos as well.
And that's one of the things that are really admire about what you do.
Like whenever something happens in the news,
it's controversial.
You have a very poignant point about,
about it.
You'll do this long,
20 minute really in depth discussion of these things.
Just,
you know,
editing,
standing right in front of a camera.
And that takes a lot of balls and it's also very impressive.
It's,
it's great stuff and you have great points.
I really enjoyed talking to you.
So Stefan Molyneux,
ladies and gentlemen,
and you could find him on Twitter.
Your Twitter is same.
Stefan Molyneux free domain radio,
but it's also Stefan Molyneux,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
that's what I yeah,
you're following me buddy.
I'm looking at you right now,
but so there's a fine domain radio when you're looking at on the screen.
That seems true that is there a free domain radio one as well?
I think there is,
yeah.
Mike is going to kill me if I get oh you have a guy that does.
Yeah,
he does it.
So I do all my Twitter shit.
Yeah.
So I have a guy that guy got,
might get mad at you put up Dick Pictures and shit.
He just,
if I get the feed wrong and he's going to be like,
I can't believe you'd do this at seven years and you can't give people your
Twitter feed.
What the Hell is wrong with you if you can't spell Stefan Molyneux our
understanding.
Yeah.
M o.
That's a crafty name,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's,
it's an F,
not a p.
H.
S.
T.
E.
F as in frank [inaudible] main radio.com is where people should go.
They get free books and podcasts and no commercials and all that kind of stuff.
So,
all right.
Comedy wise,
I will be at the standup live in Phoenix this weekend with the lovely and
talented Thomson [inaudible].
Very excited about that.
And uh,
Chicago,
Joe Rogan,
like you gave me tickets to the last live show.
It's,
it's like gut busting,
Lee.
Funny.
Thank you.
Have to go.
It's just,
it's incredible.
It's like an ab workout.
You know,
you come out with the tears in your eyes and ripples in your stomach.
I'm glad you had a good time,
man.
Thanks to our sponsors as well.
Uh,
thank you to a Lumosity Lumosity,
which is,
uh,
one of our favorite sponsors.
It is literally a gym online for your fucking brain.
Go there,
check it out.
Get in there.
Um,
it says,
do not talk about any direct benefits you've experienced since playing Lumosity.
Hmm.
Don't talk about doing direct benefits.
I won't talk about direct benefits,
but I'll tell you I enjoy it.
I like it.
Um,
it's also a very easy to do and fun.
Uh,
so go to lumosity.com and enjoy the shit out of that ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
what else can I tell you about Lumosity?
That's all I'm supposed to tell you.
I think squarespace.com,
that's our other one.
squarespace.com is a,
our favorite website when it comes to doing things like creating a website of
your own online.
I do not think there is a better choice.
squarespace.com they can create a real,
you can create a really slick professional looking website for yourself.
You can do it all online.
Go to squarespace.com enter in the code Joe and the number one that's Joe and
the number one for the month of January.
And you will save 10% off your first purchase.
And we're also doing a contest at Squarespace.
So if you use the Hashtag j r e Squarespace and tweet them one of your websites,
you can win some cool shit.
Uh,
thanks.
Also to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and shroom tech sport and all that.
Goodness.
Go there.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Tomorrow we'll be back with a author,
Scott Sigler,
a very cool guy and very interesting guy,
and it was fun talking to him the last time.
And then on Wednesday,
Dr. Mark Gordon is going to talk to us about traumatic brain injuries and
hormones and all kinds of cool shit.
So we will see you soon.
Big Love and big kiss and go fuck yourself.
All right,
bye.